foreign
Google analytics is a web analytics
service offered by Google that enables
website owners and marketers to track
and analyze various aspects of their
website's performance and user Behavior
it provides a wide range of features and
functionalities including tracking
website traffic analyzing audience
demographics and behavior monitoring
conversions and e-commerce data and
customizing reports by integrating a
tracking code into their website you can
gather valuable insights to optimize
online presence and marketing strategies
it is important to conserve the official
Google analytics documentation for the
latest updates on its capabilities as
Google regularly enhances its products
and services as per the sources in April
2022 Google analytics was used by 73
percent of the 10 000 most popular
website across the globe and around 28.1
million website use Google analytics for
their business growth on that note
simply announce post graduate program
and digital marketing is the right
choice for you to upskill and learn all
the Google analytics techniques you will
be benefited with a detailed
understanding of search engine
optimization content marketing web
analytics keyword management and
research website management and
optimization URL management search
psychology keyword organization and
match types keyword research Advanced ad
features and much more not only these
skills but you will also learn the
number of tools like SE ranking
HootSuite Facebook Instagram Google
analytics LinkedIn YouTube Twitter
Google ads Keyword Planner and more so
hurry up and find the course Link in the
description box for more details so
without any further Ado let's start
understanding Google analytics over to
our tutors
the major difference between Universal
analytics and Google analytics score is
the measurement model
Universal analytics uses sessions and
Page views as the measurement model
whereas Google analytics score uses
events and parameters as the measurement
model therefore any hit type from
Universal analytics property say a page
view user timing Etc are captured as
event in Google analytics for property
let's see the detailed comparison of
every aspect of universal analytics and
Google analytics port
first we go with events
in analytics every measurable action for
example page load form completion
Scrolls app installs Etc is measured as
event an event has category label and
action in Universal Analytics
moreover it has its own hit type
in case of Google analytics 4 there is
no categorization all the hit types from
Universal analytics are considered as
events
now let's find the comparison of
universal analytics and Google analytics
score in terms of page views
page views is a metric to find that
calculates total number of pages viewed
on your website
now let's get a better understanding of
page views
for instance when user lands on a web
page of your site the page loads this is
considered to be a page view now suppose
if user reloads the page
Google analytics tracks it as another
page view
if the user navigates to another page of
your website and returns to the same
page this adds another page view to your
site now that you have understood page
views let's see how page views differs
in Universal analytics and Google
analytics port from Universal analytics
page view are translated to Google
analytics for property
as page view event
this page view event automatically gets
triggered in Google tag manager
the next metric we have is sessions
session is a Time duration for which
user is active on your website a
universal analytics session May consist
of multiple page views events e-commerce
transactions
Etc
the session is considered to be ended if
the user has 30 minutes of inactivity or
any other event for which session end is
triggered
in Google analytics 4 session metrics
are tracked from session start event
which automatically gets triggered with
the basic interaction on your website
however the session duration depends on
the period between the first and the
last event now let's check our next
metric which is custom dimension
in Universal analytics custom Dimension
add the information to the collected
data
whereas in Google analytics 4
information is added through the event
parameters
moving ahead
the next metric we have is content
grouping content grouping in Universal
analytics allows to group content into a
logical structure
after which one can view and compare
metrics by the group name now talking
about Google analytics 4 it has
predefined event parameter for Content
group this parameter fills the data into
content group moving ahead the next
metric we have is client ID
client ID is a unique string generated
randomly and acts as a pseudonymous
identifier client ID identifies the
browser instance and then it gets stored
in the browser cookies
and therefore subsequent visits to the
same site are associated with that user
in both Universal analytics and Google
analytics score client ID serves the
same purpose that is the client ID is
responsible for providing the identifier
now let's move ahead with the next
metric
parameters
parameters are associated with Google
analytics four properties
understanding in detail about parameters
parameters are the chunk of information
that specifies the user action
for example parameters can be passed to
describe the value of the purchase
next we have is user property user
properties provide information like
preferred language a geographical
location of the users that interact with
your website or app now that we have
seen difference between Universal
analytics and Google analytics four
properties the question definitely
arises can Google analytics really bring
success to your business
well if you have a good understanding of
your audience and have extraordinary
strategies to work on the Google
analytics is your best companion
here are some success stories by Google
analytics for users we all know about
McDonald's the leading fast food
cooperation with huge number of outlets
across the globe recently a case study
has been shared by McDonald's Hong Kong
which suggests that the company has
experienced growth in conversions by 550
percent through the in-app orders and
what made them achieve such a great
growth
yes you guessed it right it's Google
analytics score
let's have a look on their success story
the major goal for the company was to
redesign the strategy to increase in-app
food orders predict the behavior of
in-app audiences and reach the right
customers with McDonald's mobile order
campaigns to achieve the goals McDonald
used a simple yet smart approach and
implemented Google analytics for
properties with the help of predictive
audiences in Google analytics for
properties they tried converting
audiences into customers
moreover with the help of Google ads
they were able to manage the campaigns
as a result of the smart efforts
McDonald was able to gain increase in
conversions by 550 percent for the users
who are likely to purchase in next 7
days
isn't it amazing moreover for the same
audience McDonald's had noticed a
visible decrease in cost per action by
63 percent
and an increase in Revenue by 560
percent
some other companies that have seen
growth in their business through Google
analytics score includes PepsiCo claro
shop
Etc simply around Spurs graduate program
and digital marketing is the right
choice for you to upskill and learn all
the Google analytics techniques so hurry
up and find the course Link in the
description box for more details and so
we're going to talk about everything
that entails including creating your
Google analytics account we're going to
talk about setting up a property in your
account and what a property is we're
going to talk about setting up a
reporting view in your property and
we're going to talk about installing the
tracking code so those are the series of
steps we're going to go through today in
terms of setting up a Google analytics
account so let's get right to it and so
really the Bruin prerequisite here when
it comes to setting up a Google
analytics account is to have a Google
login and ID so when you ask actually go
to Google analytics you need to be able
to sign up or sign in and so once you
actually sign in then you're going to go
walk through a series of steps but
really that's really all you need to get
the account going is a Google ID and
login so if you have a Gmail account or
an other email account that you use for
other Google products then you're good
to go that's all you need to do so when
you actually go to sign up for Google
analytics you're going to be asked to
set up a new account and these are the
series of steps you're going to walk
through or go through to set up a new
Google Analytics account so you're going
to choose an account name and then
you're going to choose a property name
okay so the account name can be anything
you want it to be the name your company
your name whatever you want to name it
the property name is really the website
name so what website are we talking
about so here I'm going to set up
fictitious website name for now it's
called demo simply learn so the URL for
this website demo simply learn is going
to be
demo.simplylearn.com so that's the
property when we talk about properties
in analytics we're really talking about
what websites we want to measure and
then you're going to be asked to choose
an industry category and so for simply
learn we're in jobs and education but
you have a number of different
industries that you could choose from
this is important go ahead and choose
the most relevant industry that your
particular business is associated with
okay and I'm going to talk about why
that's important here in a minute and
then you're going to choose your time
zone and the time zone is also important
because that's when the day starts in
analytics and the day ends based on that
time zone so the data that Google
analytics collects starts and ends with
that time zone so very important to
choose the time zone your business is
located located in okay and then you
have some additional options here okay
so you have some settings and so the
first setting is to allow Google
products and services so if you opt into
this then basically what Google's going
to do is share some products and
services with you via email I would go
ahead and opt into that that's of course
recommended by Google it doesn't hurt to
hear from Google on related products and
services that may enhance your business
the second is benchmarking so
benchmarking to me is something you
should opt into so going back to that
industry and category we chose jobs in
education so by opting into benchmarking
basically what Google's going to do is
share your data that it collects on your
website in this case
demo.simplylearn.com it's going to share
that data anonymously with others in the
industry in this case jobs and education
and because you've opted in it's going
to do the same exact thing for you it's
going to share Anonymous data on other
websites in the same industry and the
benefit of that is we get to see what
other websites or how other websites are
performing compared to ours what's the
Benchmark in our industry and so the
benchmarking to me is important and I'm
gonna go over that in a few minutes when
we go over the different reports but to
me I would always opt into benchmarking
because this is the only report Google
provides in analytics about how others
in your industry is performing versus
your website okay so it's a way to
compare your website performance against
others in the same industry the other
options here technical support and
account specialist I would also
recommend you opt into those because
then it allows you to basically Google
allow Google access to your account and
they'll be able to help you if you occur
or run into any issues so these are the
options in setting up a Google analytics
account it's very simple very easy to do
you're just entering in a few Fields
note that we talking about a website
right now so I'm talking about
demo.simplierlearn.com but just know
that if you want to track a mobile app
Google analytics will allow you to do
that as well you just choose the option
mobile app so we're tracking a website
we want to know how users behave when
they get to my website and that's what
Google analytics is going to allow us to
measure and look at we just need to do a
couple more steps in the process so once
we fill out these fields here we're
going to click get tracking ID now I'm
going to accept the terms of service I'm
going to accept another terms and
service in relation to data protection
I'm going to click accept once I accept
I'm going to be able to get some
tracking code the tracking ID is the ID
D associated with your account and so
this number is going to be associated
with your account so your account ID
starts with UA and it's going to be this
number here now the dash one is the
property you set up so in this case I
set up
demo.simplylearn.com if I wanted to
track multiple websites under that same
account then I can certainly set up
multiple properties just know that every
property I set up in that account is
going to have a dash 1-2-3-4
Etc depending on how many properties I
set up so by default I set up one
property so my first property ID is dash
one if I set up a second property the
same account number it's just gonna have
a dash two and that's important because
that ID that account and property ID is
going to be associated with that
particular property or website so again
once you finish setting up the account
settings then you're going to be asked
to add some tracking code to your site
and that tracking code is going to be
related to the account and the property
so notice my tracking ID up here notice
the tracking ID in the snippet of code
now this snip and a code needs to go on
every page of your website that you want
to track and you don't have to put it on
every page but if you want to track
website behavior on every page or
website then it needs to go on every
page of your website so if you're using
a you know platform like Drupal or
Joomla or even more popular platform
like WordPress adding the tracking code
site-wide is as easy as maybe adding a
Google analytics plugin to Wordpress for
example and then just simply plug in in
the ID now there's an alternative to
adding the Google analytics tracking
code to your site and that's Google tag
manager so Google tag manager is the way
I would recommend going so if you're not
familiar with Google tag manager I would
recommend watching the YouTube video we
have on Google tag manager you can just
go to YouTube Type in simply learn
Google tag manager and this will give
you a nice overview of you know what
Google tag manager is and how it works
but basically this is the way I would go
and I would recommend that in addition
having Google analytics you set up a
Google tag manager account and then that
way you can put the tracking code in
Google tag manager so if I go to Google
tag manager and I just go into an
account on tag manager I can just simply
put in the Google analytics ID right
into tag manager and so if I have it in
tag manager then tag manager is going to
be the place that holds the code and
file buyers page view when somebody
comes to my website so that way I don't
have to add the tracking code to my
website if I do it in tag manager so
that's the recommended method for me is
to add the Google analytics ID
associated with tag manager if you can
associate it with tag manager then
that's the easier route to go versus
putting code on your website okay so
again take a look at the video we have
on YouTube for Google tag manager that's
the route I would go now once you do get
the tracking code on your website
whether that be through Google tag
manager or through a Plugin or you know
just simply adding the script to your
site to pages on your site then what's
going to happen is you're going to start
collecting data so that's ideally the
way it works you need to add this code
to your website now if you're not ready
to do that and you simply want to
basically understand how Google
analytics works then I would recommend
getting access to Google analytics demo
account and so if you just type in and
search Google analytics demo account
basically what you're going to do you're
going to choose the first listing there
and you're going to go to demo account
so if you have a Google analytics or
Google login then all you need to do is
click on access demo account and so what
Google is going to do is put this demo
account into your account and so it's
going to look something like this so if
I click on demo account here it's going
to add to my Google analytics account so
I'm going to have then access to the
demo account from Google and Google
analytics so I would recommend going
this route here if you're not familiar
or you're not sure what you're getting
yourself into so think of the demo
account as kind of a test drive you're
test driving Google analytics before you
even add any code to your website so
again all you need is a Google account
and if you have a Google account out and
you add the demo account to your Google
analytics account you're going to be
able to see how analytics works okay and
so that's what I would also recommend so
if you're not ready to start adding code
to your website then what you can do is
just simply add the demo account and
then once you add the demo account
you're free to peruse around Google
analytics to see the different types of
reports it has to offer now when you do
actually set up a Google analytics
account you're going to have some
settings that you're going to want to
pay attention to so when you set up the
account you have the account name and
then you have a property so under each
property you have by default you're
going to have one View and so here you
can see this view here so if we look at
the account we set up we set up a demo
simply learn account property is demo
simply learned so that's associated with
the website we're going to track and
then again by default under each
property you're going to have of a view
and so by default the name of the view
is going to be called all website data
and so in that view is where all your
analytics data is going to be stored so
you can see my screen here there's a lot
of different settings you have you have
settings under the account you have
settings under the property and you have
settings under the view so we're going
to talk more about these settings and
future webinars for advanced Google
analytics users but for now know that
there's a bunch of settings that you
have that you can play around with when
it comes to Google analytics anything
from adding users to your Google
analytics account your Google analytics
property or view you can actually set up
goals you can set up filters you can set
up segments you can link up Google ads
you can you know set up remarketing list
there's a lot you can do in terms of the
settings as it relates to Google
analytics but so know those settings are
there there they're located right down
here and this little sprocket icon
that's the admin icon so if you need to
get to these settings at any time you
could simply just click on the sprocket
or the admin icon and then you'll be
prompted to choose any one of these
settings here that you want to edit or
alter so now let's take a look at some
Google analytics reports so once you've
actually set up your account you have a
number of different reports that you
have available to you in Google
analytics so we're going to take a look
at you know customized reports we're
going to look at real time audience
reports acquisition behavior and
conversion so these are all the
different reporting buckets if you will
that you have available to you in Google
analytics so if I'm an admin and I'm
looking at the Google demo account let's
start out by looking at real time so if
I click on the real time report and I
just click on overview so basically what
this is going to do is show me at this
point in time how many users I actually
have active on the website okay so
that's why they call it real time
reporting because it allows you to see
the behavior of users who are currently
on your website and so this is the
overview report under real time and you
can see here I can see that 79 percent
of my users are coming from desktop 18
20 are coming from mobile and then
approximately three percent are coming
from tablet here I can see how they
actually came to the website so this is
the referring Source if they came from
say search or social I can see the
source there and I can see what pages
they're active on and then here I could
see what locations where they're located
and so if I want to see a breakdown of
everything in the overview I can
certainly do that if I go to locations
under real time I could see a majority
of my users are coming from the United
States okay where are they coming from
I'll just click on traffic sources and
here I could see the different sources
and mediums medium is the means in which
the traffic was driven so if it's Google
it's either paid search or organic
search so I can see here it's organic
then I can actually see what contents
they're looking at on my website so I
could see currently I have three active
users on the home page two active users
on the Google's women's white t page so
forth and so on now most importantly if
you have event tracking setup so if
you're taking a look at our Google tag
manager webinar you know that you could
set up event tracking in Google
analytics to measure engagement on your
website whether that be a form
submission or somebody clicking on the
play button of a video so if I click on
events I'll be able to see what events
are firing so here I can see see we have
event tracking set up and I can see how
many different events are firing on my
website in real time so here I can see
e-commerce somebody clicking on the
quick view click some a couple of users
clicking on add to cart a couple of
users clicking on the promotion click
and as these events are fired you're
going to be able to see them highlighted
so if something gets fired it's going to
get highlighted and I could see that
these are the current events that I have
currently firing on the website and
that's what's currently fire now if I
want to look at the events that have
happened in the last 30 minutes I could
just click on this link here last 30
minutes and it's going to give me an
overview of the events that have
happened over the past 30 minutes okay
so that's event tracking and then more
importantly we can also look at what
conversions are happening in real time
just by clicking on conversions and so
now I can see I had one active user who
to enter the checkout so that's goal
number four so in analytics you can have
up to 20 goals and so here I can see we
have goal number four has already had
one active user and so if I look at the
last 30 minutes I can see I still have
only one goal over the last 30 minutes
and that was somebody who entered the
checkout so that's real time reporting
in summary it just gives you an idea of
what's currently happening on your
website and so for me ideally if I'm
launching a campaign or let's just say
you do a new website redesign and you
want to see how users performing and
behaving then real time is a good option
for you so you can see how things are
happening in real time now let's jump
down to audience reporting so if I click
on audience this is just right
underneath real time I'm gonna see a
number of different reports available to
me under audience and so let's click on
the audience overview report so audience
reporting basically allows us to get a
sense of who is coming to our website
when I say who is coming to our website
it doesn't necessarily have to be a
specific person in fact Google doesn't
allow personally identifiable
information in Google analytics personal
identifiable information such as a
specific name uh social security number
credit card information
Etc however we can still paint a nice
picture on who is coming to our website
meaning what country city or state did
they come from what language what device
did they get to our website from how old
were they okay were they male or female
or other what interests do they have
what browser do they use so we can paint
a nice picture based on all this
information that Google analytics is
providing us under audience so if I go
to audience overview here I can see I
have all these different options
available to me to get a basic
understanding of who is coming to our
website so for example I could see a
majority of the people coming to our
website speak English and are from the
United States okay in fact that
represents 61 of the users and so Google
analytics does a great job of giving me
an overall percentage so if I have a
hundred percent of the users I could see
61 percent of those users represented
English speaking users from the United
States seven percent represented
English-speaking users from Great
Britain and so when it comes to
analytics we have users and users are
broken down into two categories they're
either returning or they're new so when
you add the Google analytics tracking
script to your website what's gonna
happen is if a user or when a user goes
to your website they're gonna get
cookied if it's the first time they've
been here website what Google analytics
is going to do is store a cookie in the
browser so when that same user comes
back another day in the same browser
analytics is going to recognize that
that cookie is in the browser and so
then analytics is going to categorize
that user as a returning user okay so
that's how analytics is able to
differentiate new versus returning so if
that user doesn't have a cookie in the
browser then analytics is going to
recognize that store the cookie and then
count that user as a new user and so
when you're looking at analytics you're
going to be able to see a breakdown of
new versus returning so here I can see
over three quarters of my traffic over
the past week here I can see April 6
through April 12th three over three
quarters are new users to the website
here I could see about 23 24 are
returning users okay so I can get a good
breakdown of what type of users are
coming am I driving any traffic am I
driving traffic that's been to my
website before what language are they
speaking okay I can also paint a bigger
picture how old are they are they what
gender are they do they come from mobile
so let's take a look at some of these
different reports under audience and so
if I skip down now to demographics I can
click on overview and when that report
loads I can see now under demographics
overview I can see the breakout of age
ranges and so here I can see the
majority of the traffic coming to my
site again over the past week now if I
want to change this date range I could
simply do that I can change the date
range just by clicking on the date range
and then maybe going say the last 30
days and I can even compare it to the
previous period or the previous year I'm
going to choose the last 30 days I'm
going to click apply now I'm looking at
data over the last 30 days and again you
can change the date range to any range
you want you can only go back as far as
when you actually created the Google
analytics account you can't go prior to
that so here I'm looking at the last 30
days and I can see almost 47 of my users
were in their age range of 25 to 34. now
when it comes to gender I can say 66
percent represent males so I can get a
breakout of gender and age as well as
interest and click on interest and look
at the overview there and see what the
interest is of the users who are coming
to my site based on in-market segments
or Affinity I can also choose language
and location so if I want to know
exactly where my users are located when
they're coming to my website I can click
on location and here I can get a
breakout 43 of the users of the last 30
days were from the United States more
importantly I can align my audience with
goals and we'll talk about goals here in
a minute but here I can see if I have an
e-commerce website I can see of those 43
percent 0.29 of those converted or
purchased something and that equates to
94 transactions so I can get a good
sense of not only how many users are
coming from a specific country but are
those users converting if I click on
mobile and mobile to me is one of those
reports I tend to spend a bit of time on
because I want to know what devices
users are coming to my website and so
for my website here or this is the
Google demo website I can see mobile
represents approximately 27 of the
traffic so desktop still represents a
majority of the traffic so for you you
want to keep an eye on mobile because
mobile is definitely a majority of what
people use nowadays that's how people
start their day that's how they transact
Via Mobile whether that's purchasing
something communicating or searching it
all starts with mobile so you want to
keep an eye on mobile and more
importantly you want to keep an eye on
Behavior so Google analytics is telling
me that yes I have approximately 27 of
my traffic of the last 30 days came from
mobile how are they interacting with my
website so if I look across this report
I'm going to be able to see different
metrics so if I'm measuring specific
metrics against my dimension in this
case the dimension is what we're
measuring and in this example we're
measuring mobile I can see that the
bounce rate is approximately 48 and
bounce rate means that if a user in this
case for mobile landed on a page they
left the site without going any further
so they consider it a bounce if they
don't go to another page if they leave
the site from the page they landed on
and they don't go any further that's
considered a bounce so bounce rate is
the percentage of people who come to the
site and leave the site without going
any further so in this case we have 48
bounce rate that's almost half of our
users who come from mobile leave the
website from the page they landed on so
is that good is that bad well it's open
to interpretation is definitely
subjective but you want to keep the
bounce rate as low as possible you want
to keep people on your site especially
if you have an e-commerce website you
want people who come to your website to
purchase and so here we can see 48
Mobile in desktop it's a little bit
lower at 41 percent now if I look a
little bit further at engagement I can
see how many any pages on average do
mobile users look at so versus desktop
it's a little bit lower you can see 3.86
on desktop it's 4.5 now if I look a
little bit further in engagement I want
to be able to measure how long somebody
from mobile stays on the website if
they're bouncing at 48 but they're also
looking at 3.8 Pages 3.9 almost four
pages per session then that means in
this report analytics is telling me
they're spending about two minutes on
the site and interestingly enough I can
see that mobile of the last 30 days had
more transactions so 51 transactions
versus 34 transactions from desktop and
interestingly enough the e-commerce
conversion rate is at 0.29 percent
that's higher than desktop at .07 it's
lower than tablet but it's higher than
desktop and mobile how has the most
transactions and since they have the
most transactions they have the most
Revenue at 2 380. so yes the engagement
isn't exactly as great as it is this
desktop but we can see that people are
still purchasing with their mobile
devices so it's something to keep an eye
on and mobile is something I definitely
look at in fact since it's such an
important report one thing you can do in
analytics is if you actually like a
report and you think you're going to
look at that report multiple times then
you can simply just go ahead and click
save at the top here so if I click save
I'm going to enter a name for this
report I'm just going to call it mobile
report and click OK and then what's
going to happen is it's going to be
located under save reports and save
reports is located under customization
customization is located above real time
okay so if I close that up you can see
audience real time customization if I
click on customization if I click on
Save reports I should be able to see my
save report here and I do so here I can
see mobile report if I click on it I can
simply go to the report I was looking at
before I saved it so save reports to me
is a good feature and analytics because
it allows you to quickly access a report
that you've saved in the past so let's
take a look at one more report under
audience and let's go to benchmarking so
remember when we're setting up our
analytics account we had the option to
opt into benchmarking and I recommended
you do so and so if you did I actually
opt into benchmarking then you're going
to be able to see how your site compares
to others in the same industry so if I
click on benchmarking and then click on
channels what I'm actually able to do
now is compare my website with others in
the same industry so if I go back to say
jobs in education and I choose education
all education as my industry vertical I
should be able to see websites that are
in the same particular industry and how
I compare with those websites so I'm
choosing all countries I can narrow that
down if I wanted to I can just search
for the United States I can choose a
specific State and then I can choose a
particular site size so here I'm
choosing sites by daily session so these
are sites that have an average of 5 000
to almost 10 000 sessions a day and so
in this vertical education in the United
States sites that have five thousand to
nine thousand nine hundred ninety nine
sessions per day that means that they're
approximately 310 web properties
contributing to this report okay based
on this criteria I chose now if my site
is similar meaning if I'm in the United
States if I'm in education and I'm
receiving five thousand to nine thousand
nine hundred ninety nine sessions per
day then I'm able to compare my site
against 310 other websites now Google's
sharing this data anonymously from the
other websites and they're doing the
same with your website to those
particular websites benchmarking reports
okay so it's a shared data anonymously
in particular Industries and verticals
and so now I'm looking at a channel
report so if I want to see how I compare
to others in my industry then I can go
ahead and see by channel for example in
my driving as much traffic as others in
my industry and you can see I'm not in
fact I'm 76 77 percent worse in terms of
the amount of traffic being driven from
organic search so anything in red is
going to show as a negative result a
negative comparison where is something
in green is a positive comparison so if
I look at engagement I can see that I
might not be driving as much traffic but
I can see that the pages per session are
better than the site average or the
industry average I can see if I go over
again looking just at organic search I
can see the bounce rate is better than
the industry average so the channel
report under benchmarking allows you to
measure how you compare to others in
your industry and you could do so by
looking at location and devices so if
you opted into benchmarking when you set
up your account then you'll be able to
compare your website against others in
your industry in your country region and
based on the size of your website in
terms of how many visitors or sessions
you're getting per day so let's go from
audience to acquisition so if audience
is who is coming to your website
acquisition allows us to see how the
traffic traffic was driven to your
website so how do these users get to our
website and so under acquisition if we
click on overview we'll be able to see
an overview of how users whether they're
returning are new came to our website
and so what analytics does by default is
they have a number of default channels
and when we say channels we mean
analytics is grouping different channels
based on how users got to your website
meaning how did users get to our
websites they come via organic search
meaning do they type something into
Google and find you in the organic
listing analytics also groups users
based on whether they came to your site
directly meaning did they type in the
URL directly into the browser or did
they bookmark your website and come back
via the bookmark so they're grouping
users under direct they also group users
under referral meaning do they come from
another web website they group users by
social do they come from a social media
platform like Twitter or Facebook if
you're running paid search meaning if
you're running paid search on say Google
then do they come from Paid search ads
now if you're running display ads on say
Google's Network Google's Display
Network that's a default channel so
analytics for group users there so if
they don't recognize a channel then
they're going to group it as others so
by default Google analytics groups users
and how they came to your website via
these default channels and so I can see
how many users came to the site from
each Channel now if I want to drill down
on this report I can click on all
traffic and then if I click on all
traffic I can go to channels I can look
specifically at the channels report and
so now I can see organic search again
over the last 30 days is the number one
channel driving traffic and they
represent is an approximately again you
can see this number here in parentheses
next to the raw number of users I can
see that number is about 56 percent so
56 percent of my traffic over the last
30 days came from organic search and so
those are the number of users again as a
metric you're also going to have
sessions and you'll see sessions a lot
as a metric so users are broken down
between new and returning so every time
a new or returning user comes to the
website basically what they're doing is
initiating a session so you can have a
user who can come back multiple times
every time they come back to the website
it's a session so session is simply the
start of somebody coming to your website
and the session ends when they leave the
website and so just like we looked at
with the audience reports when it came
to mobile we can also look at engagement
by channel so just like mobile we looked
at bounce rate pages per session average
session duration we can do the same
thing here with our Channel report more
importantly in addition to behavior we
can see conversions and since we're
running an e-commerce platform we could
see what the conversion rate is by
channel so organic search did drive the
most traffic and they did have the most
transactions over the last 30 days and
the conversion rate in this case is 0.17
okay so how Google determines the
conversion rate they basically take the
number of transactions and divide that
by sessions so that means that over the
last 30 days organic search drove 38 123
sessions and of those 38 000 123 64
actually turned into a transaction which
equates to 0.17 which also equates to 3
000 in Revenue so I'm able to determine
not only how users are getting to my
website by looking at the channel report
I can actually see if they're engaging
and if they are converting and notice
when you look at a report in analytics
you can look at it by Channel you'll
also get a summary so here I can see a
summary or a total based on my date
range so I could see over the last 30
days I've had 54 000 users 49
000 of them were new okay that meant
that out of those four fifty four
thousand users I had 70 000 sessions I
could see my average bounce rate was 43
percent the pages per session were just
over four and the average session
duration how long did somebody stay on
my website on average about two minutes
and 55 seconds the average conversion
rate was 0.14 and I had a total of 97
transactions totaling fifty five hundred
dollar dollars okay and that's all over
the last 30 days so any report you look
at in analytics is going to have a
summary and note that any report you
look at in analytics is going to allow
you to save it so if it's a report you
think you're going to go back and look
at at a future date then you simply just
have to click on the save button
conversely if you don't want to save it
you can simply just export it so you can
export it as a PDF if I click on PDF
it's going to allow me to export that as
a PDF now you have other options
available to you as well you can do a
Google sheet you can export it as an
Excel or you can export it as a common
delimited file so here you can see I can
save it as a PDF if I want to and if I
click OK it's going to save to my
desktop or location of my choosing and
then I can go back and look at it in
that format at a later time so that's
the export feature available to you in
analytics again if you you could save it
as well or you can export it okay some
other reports under acquisition if
you're running Google ads note that you
can connect Google ads to analytics and
this is key because now I can see how
many people are coming from Google ads
to my website and are they converting
now this is important because with
Google ads I'm actually paying for the
click so you can see here I'm running a
report based on campaign data so I could
see what campaigns are driving traffic
how much I'm paying per click and you
can see on average I'm paying 34 cents
per click and then more importantly I
want to be able to see if they're
converting so you can see I've spent 810
dollars over the last 30 days and
received 858 dollars in Revenue so you
want to make sure that you link up your
Google ads account to your Google
analytics account for for this very
reason you want to be able to see how
your Google ads campaigns perform once
the users get to your website and so I
want to see if they're engaging and I
want to see if they're converting so
they're all sorts of reports under
Google ads so you can look at it by
keywords by search queries by hour of
the day if you're running display
campaigns you can look at display
targeting it says all sorts of reports
under Google ads you just have to link
it up and you link it up under the admin
now there are other reports that you can
look at so if I go to campaigns I can
look at all campaigns so if you're
running all sorts of different types of
campaigns whether that be on Facebook
whether it be email whether that be you
know other types of advertising let's
just say Twitter or Instagram you're
going to be able to see those campaigns
here and that's under all campaigns and
again you'll be able to see the campaign
name and you'll be able to see metrics
associated with those campaigns and more
importantly you'll be able to see your
e-commerce if you're running e-commerce
platform or if you have goals set up so
you'll be able to look at how your
campaigns are not one not only driving
traffic but two are they converting
let's go from acquisition reporting to
behavior so Behavior reports are going
to actually show you how users behaved
once they got to your website once they
landed on a page on your website how did
they behave so when we looked at
audience we got a sense of who is coming
with acquisition we get a sense of how
the traffic got to our website did they
come from organic direct social Etc the
behavior reports allow us to actually
measure how that traffic behave once
they landed on a page on our website and
so if I go to overview under Behavior
now I'm looking at this graph here it's
showing me how many pages Jews have had
and a page view is simply once a page is
viewed it's counted as a page view so if
a user comes to my site they're
initiating a session and if they look at
a page then that page is going to have a
page view okay so a user can look at a
page multiple times in a session and
every time they look at that page it's
going to count as a page view so here I
can see in this graph how many pages
I've had again over the last 30 days and
if I look further at my overview report
I can see the specific pages and how
many pages they've had and I can also
look at some other metrics okay the
average bounce rate the average time on
page I can look at the exit rate which
means how many people actually exited or
the percentage of people who exited from
that page so I can dig deeper into my
behavior reporting so if I click on site
content and I click on all pages then
I'm going to look look at a report by
Page this is my Dimension this is what
I'm measuring my page and now I can see
how many page views each page had over
the last 30 days now note you also have
something called unique page views so
unique page use is equivalent to one per
session in other words if a user came to
my site and looked at the home page then
the home page is going to have one
unique page view and one page view now
if the user in that same session looks
at other Pages then every page that user
looks at it's going to have one unique
page view however if the user goes back
to another to the same page in the same
session then it's still going to be one
unique page view but in this case the
home page if they look at the home page
a second time then the home page is
going to have two page views if they
look at the home page five times in one
session then the home page is gonna have
five total page views and one unique
page view okay so that's why you unique
pages is equivalent to one per session
where pages is an accumulation of how
many times the page was viewed in the
same session so in other words you're
always going to have more page views
than unique pages okay so this gives me
a sense of how my pages performed so
again I can look at total page views and
then engagement so ideally what you want
to do with a report like this is if a
user is not engaging on the page then
that should tell you something about the
page itself if they're not engaging if
the bounce rate's high if the time on
page is low if the exit percentage of
exit rate is high then you probably want
to do something with that page now these
are all pages but if I jump down to
landing pages my landing page report is
showing me how many people actually
landed on that page and so here I can
see under my landing page report I can
see the home page had thirty six
thousand seven teen sessions in the last
30 days that's how many people landed on
the home page so here I can see 71
percent were news sessions meaning that
I had a lot of new users who landed on
the home page in fact 25
000 or 52 percent of the people who
landed on the home page were new I could
see the bounce rates about 42 percent
but of those who didn't bounce they went
on to look at about 4.5 pages per
session and spent about three minutes on
the site and the one thing I like about
the landing page report is I can also
see whether that particular page in this
case the home page did it help
contribute to a goal or conversion and
in this case I can see of those 36 000
sessions I had 22 transactions totaling
1200 in revenue and that's an e-commerce
conversion rate of 0.06 percent so the
home page oh over the last 30 days
contributed to 0.06 percent of the
revenue so this gives you an idea of
when somebody lands on your website and
they land on a page is that page helping
to move that person along meaning are
they not bouncing and is that page
helping to move people towards
converting and so that's what the
landing page in effect allows us to
measure is the engagement and in this
case we're measuring transactions okay
so analytics also gives us some other
reports under Behavior including site
speed so site speed to me is an
important report to look at just like
the mobile report to me site speed is
important because with Google analytics
does is they take a sampling of pages
and in this case you can see over the
last 30 days they sampled
2835 page views and of that sample they
came back and said the average pay age
low time is about four seconds now
ideally you want to keep it as quick as
possible I would say even under three
seconds okay now there are other factors
involved with page load time the browser
you're using the country that you're
actually browsing that page from might
know how to have the best infrastructure
you may not even be on the best internet
Network meaning you're on a cell network
or the Wi-Fi is not that gray or you can
be on a page that just has a lot of
images or a lot of code that may slow it
down so there are other factors involved
and so what Google analytics does is
show you what those factors are so here
I can see by browser what the average
load time is if I want to look at
Country I could see what country is
contributing to the load time now the
great thing about the site speed report
is if I go to speed suggestions okay
what speed suggestions is going to do is
it's going to show me the pay age load
Time by Page and then it's actually
going to provide a link where I can
actually click on to get suggestions on
increasing the page load time so for
example I can look at this particular
page here this Google redesign shop by
brand slash YouTube page line number
five if I look at line number five I can
see the average load time of this page
is eight seconds almost nine seconds
okay that's an eternity to some people
now notice this link next to it so
Google's recommending seven total
suggestions so if I click on seven total
what it's actually going to do it's
going to open up a new window and it's
going to open up another Google report
called page speed insights and Page
speed insights is going to give me some
information about what I can do to
create correct correct the page load of
that particular page so look at the site
speed report it's important because
there is a correlation Nation between
site speed or page load time and user
behavior of that page and there's also
correlation between page load time and a
page ranking organically on search so
page load time is very important it's so
important that I'm even going to save it
so I'm going to click save and click on
speed site speed suggestions as my name
and click OK and now that report is
going to be saved under customization
under save reports let's jump from
Behavior to conversions now conversion
reporting is arguably the most important
section in in Google analytics because
what the conversions reporting allows us
to do is see how people are converting
or if they're not converting on our
website and so in Google analytics we
have the opportunity to set up goals now
you have the opportunity to set up 20
goals in your Google analytics View and
so to set up a goal okay so you're gonna
click on admin and Under The View you're
going to see goals and so if you don't
even have goals the first step is to
create goals and so you have four
different goal types and analytics so
you have pages per session so how many
pages per session is so if your goal is
set to say three or two if somebody
actually looked at two or three pages
per session it's going to count as a
goal okay so if I look here I can see I
have pages per session set at 10. so
that means that if a user came to the
site looked at more than 10 pages per
session then it's going to count as a
goal another goal type is destination so
destination means that if somebody
actually went to a specific page then
it's going to count as a goal and in
this case I can see here that the goal
is set to this particular page here and
so when somebody actually lands on that
page it's going to count as a goal now
there are two other goal ties we can
look at one is duration so just like
pages per session in our previous
example is somebody looked at 10 pages
per session it's going to count as a
goal with duration it's based on time so
in this particular case if you set up a
duration goal and the duration is set to
say one minute and 30 seconds then that
means if a user comes to my website and
they spend at least one minute and 30
seconds then it's going to count as a
goal okay and then the fourth type of
goal in Google analytics is an event
based goal so when you set up event
tracking you could turn that event into
a goal so if somebody clicks on say the
submit button of a form you can turn
that event into a goal so here you can
see the category equals contact form so
you can always verify if a goal works
just by clicking on verify this goal and
in this case this event is turned into a
goal so anytime somebody fires this
event it's going to count as a goal so
you have four different goal types in
Google analytics you have pages per
session destination event and duration
and so once you've set up a goal then
you can measure goals under conversions
so now if I look at goals overview I can
be able to see how many total goal
completions I've had so if I want to
look at it by goal I can just choose the
goal option here so if I want to look at
for example goal 2 engaged users this
was the pages per session I can see that
I had a conversion rate of 10 meaning
that I had 7 000 of all the users that
came to the website 7 000 goal
completions meaning
7106 users looked at 10 pages or more on
my website and so that's how you want
want to be able to measure whether users
wherever they're coming from whoever
they are whatever Pages they look at you
want to be able to look at the
conversion reports to see if they're
actually converting based on the goals
you've set up whether that's pages per
session duration destination or event
goal conversion tracking reports can
help you measure who is actually
converting and the great thing about
Google analytics here is that I can
actually see by segments so the default
segment in a segment is just looking at
a specific user set so the default
segment is always all users however I
can choose a different segment so if I
want to choose instead of all users if I
want to choose Mobile Traffic I can
select Mobile Traffic hit apply so I'm
actually now looking at a subset of data
I'm looking at mobile traffic so if all
the mobile users have come to my site I
I can say 1400 engaged or looked at 10
pages or more okay and that's a seven
percent conversion rate so the great
thing about Google analytics is you have
the opportunity to set up four different
goal types okay based on those goal
types you can go to goals overview and
look at the conversion rates of each
goal but you can also change the
segments of that particular goal to see
who exactly converted okay another
report I like under conversions is the
multi-channel funnel report so if I
click on multi-channel funnel basically
what this allows me to do is see how
different channels work together to
convert so remember the channel
reporting we looked at under acquisition
here I can see now how different
channels work together to drive the
conversion so if I look at three
channels direct organic and referral I
can see all three together drive two
percent of the conversions if I look at
direct referral twelve and a half
percent if I look at direct and organic
12.24 so I can see how different
channels work together and so if I look
at top conversion paths as an example I
can actually see what channels how
channels work together to drive the
conversion so in this example I can see
over the last 30 days that my top
channel grouping was direct times two
meaning that somebody came to the
website directly meaning they typed in
the URL in the browser or they
bookmarked it and came to the site okay
they came the first time but didn't
convert but then they came back a second
time via direct and then converted so
that combination is my top conversion
combination over the last 30 days my
second best conversion grouping is
organic search and direct meaning that a
user came to the website via organic
search first did not convert and then
came back via direct the second time and
converted so basically what analytics
does is give credit to the last referral
meaning if you came to the website via
referral or referring website and
converted then the referring website's
gonna get the credit for the conversion
but analytics does a good job of showing
you how different channels work together
so a channel may drive a lot of traffic
like organic search but that traffic may
not convert the first time around for a
number of different reasons whether it
could be brand recognition Price
shopping reading content whatever the
case analytics is able to measure if
that channel actually did contribute at
a later point and in this case we could
see organic search drove traffic that
didn't convert but that traffic came
back a second time via direct and did
convert so that's our second best
Channel grouping and so the
multi-channel funneling Report top
conversion pass to me is a good report
to look at so you can actually see not
only have channels work together but you
can see sources and mediums and
campaigns and how all that all those
different campaigns from different
sources work together to convert so
that's just a good report to look at
there are so many different reports
available in analytics there's so many
that we haven't even gotten to yet so my
advice if you look at the demo report
you can get a feel for each of these
reports under each section whether that
be audience acquisition Behavior or
conversions take a look at these reports
see what makes sense to you see what you
can use to improve your website
performance for this particular webinar
we're going to jump into Google
analytics directly and spend all of our
time there because it's about learning
practical applications so goals are
important goals so let me just say this
goals are in analytics something that
should be aligned with your business and
we call goals that are align with your
business kpis are key performance
indicators so it's very important as a
precursor that you know how to set up
goals in Google analytics because if
you're using Google analytics you want
to measure everything against the goal
so without further Ado let's jump right
into Google analytics so if I go to
Google analytics and I log in okay what
I want to do is go down to admin click
on admin here and admin will take you to
basically a screen that looks like this
where you have an account column you
have your property column and then you
have review column now the view column
is where you're going to go to set up
goals okay so every view in every
property has up to 20 goals okay so by
default in analytics you're going to
have at least one view for your property
so if I have a property I'm gonna have
at least one view but if I happen to set
up multiple views like you see here then
I know for every view I set up I have 20
goals to work with so where are those
goals so Under The View I'm going to
click on goals and now I could see I
have 20 at my disposal now you can see
here by clicking on the recording column
I can see I have in this particular
property this particular view I have
five goals that are active so you can
use up to 20 but you don't have to have
20 active Okay you can have one active
two active my recommendation is least
have one goal again when you set up a
goal you're going to measure everything
in analytics against that goal okay so
in this case we have five particular
goals we're measuring so we have five
active out of 20 total so if I don't no
longer want to use a goal I could simply
just turn it off if I want to continue
using it just turn it on okay it's that
simple you could turn on and off goals
so here I already have five set up so if
you want to set up a new goal the one
thing you need to know in Google
analytics is in order to set up a new
goal okay you need to have edit access
at least the view level I would say at
the property level so you want to make
sure whoever's in charge of Google
analytics for your organization or if
you're in charge okay you simply just
want to go to user management and user
management you want to make sure the
email address you're using to log into
Google analytics has at least edit
permissions so you're gonna need edit
permissions to add new goals so so I
have edit permissions I'm going to go to
goals and I want to set up a new goal
but before we jump in and set up a new
goal what is it that we want to achieve
that's really the question we want to
ask ourselves what is the goal of the
website well if it's somebody
downloading something okay are you
measuring that download via an event
okay are they filling out a form
submission before they download so if
they submit that form submission is that
the goal or do you have any Commerce
side is somebody purchasing something so
these are things you want to ask
yourself before you actually set up the
goal what is it that I'm trying to
measure now when you actually do go to
set up a goal you're going to click on
the red CTA button that says new goal so
analytics actually has some templates
set up for you okay you can see them
here okay if you're somebody's
registering online or creating an
account or reading review downloading
something sharing something you could
choose all of these options here what I
normally do is choose custom 99 of the
time I'm just going to choose custom it
doesn't really matter if you use the
template or not it's just a template is
basically some free pre-filled
configurations but my recommendation is
always just go with custom you want
total control over how to set up your
goal so we already have in mind what
type of goal we want to set up so for
example if somebody goes to fill out a
form submission and they go to a thank
you page after that well what's the URL
of that thank you page we want to be
able to track how many people go to that
page because we know if somebody does
type in or fill in a form submission and
goes to that page we know that they
filled out the form and so for example
if I go to continue I'm going to name my
goal first so I'm going to a thank you
page as an example notice analytics is
assigning an ID so notice this is goal
ID 15. that means that that's the next
available goal there are 20 goals
available in analytics and so what
analytics does is they group goals
together so one through five six through
ten eleven through fifteen sixteen
through twenty into goal sets so for
example goal 16 through 20 is part of
goal set for and why does Google
analytics combine these goals into
different goal sets well because it's
easier to measure and look at data by
goal sets so for example if I jump into
any report here if I go to all traffic
channels and I want to measure how many
goals by Channel I can look at it by
goal set so if I have goal set one
selected then I know any goal I have
active in there between goal id1 through
goal id5 I'm going to be able to see
those goals and goal set one and now I'm
going to be able to measure every goal I
have active and goal set one against the
channel so if I choose goal set two
whatever goals are active there goal set
three Etc notice I don't have any goals
16 through 20 active that earn goal set
four therefore I don't have that option
available to me so back to admin the
bottom left navigation again goals okay
we want to measure somebody going to the
thank you page we have edit access we're
going to choose custom as our goal setup
we're going to type in a goal name I'm
just going to say thank you okay this is
goal 15. now this is the important part
Google analytics has four different goal
types destination duration pages per
session or screens per session to
screens per session is related to mobile
because Google analytics measures mobile
app activity and then you have an event
so we're going to cover all four of
these but for the sake of this simple
example I'm going to choose destination
why because if somebody goes to that
thank you page we're going to go ahead
and put in the thank you page as the
goal the goal URL so for example
destination is my choice I'm going to
click continue now this is where I'm
gonna put the URL so if my URL is just
simply thank you.html I can just go
ahead and put thank you.html or if it's
just thank you then I can just do thank
you depends on the website depends on
the URI structure so whatever that URL
is that's what you're going to put in
and when you're done you can verify it
so what Google analytics does is
actually we'll verify over the last
seven days if anybody's actually gone to
that particular page so if we click
verify we could see zero percent
conversion rate so that tells us that if
this is the correct URL then we've had
zero percent people go to that page this
is just an example however if you didn't
see a conversion then you might want to
make sure you check the URL here that
you put in and if you do see a
conversion rate then you know it's
working so Google analytics actually has
options so we're saying thank you is
equal to so the destination URL is equal
to thank you or thank you.html or thank
you dot ESP or whatever that thank you
page is okay you do have options so if
you have a long URL you could say it
begins with and you could say begins
with say thank you so this is the logic
we're going to say hey if anybody goes
to a URL that begins with thank you
think count it as a goal or you could
say equals two so if anybody goes to a
URL that equals two thank you then then
count it as a goal you have one more
option Here regular expression so Google
analytics understands the language of
regular Expressions so regular Express
expressions are just special characters
used to communicate with Google
analytics in order to hone in on exactly
what you're trying to track so we can
always say you know starts with or ends
with so we can you know use characters
like the dollar sign ends with or begins
with so we can always do that so you can
use regular Expressions as well if
you're familiar with regular Expressions
if you're not then you don't have to use
them but there are special characters
where that you can insert in that are
used as regular expression so if you're
not familiar with regular expression
don't choose that option you could
choose the other option of equals to or
begins with now note that on all three
of these options I didn't put the domain
so if my my domain is
amadashfoundation.org Slash and then
thank you I don't need to put the domain
because analytics is already knows what
domain we're tracking so you don't have
to put in the domain here when you're
entering in in this case the Google URL
so you can omit the domain so when you
put in that URL you know that you have
three options to work with and then you
always always want to verify that goal
URL you always want to verify it because
if you see zero percent conversion and
in this case of the last seven days then
that should tell you something either
your goal is not set up correctly or you
just don't have any conversions either
way you want to double check that now
when it comes to the destination URL
goal you do have an option here for
funnel so if I turn on funnel then that
means I have the ability to track how
people went through my phone so if I
have a cart and I want to be able to
check how many people go in and out of
the cart then I have the option of
adding specific Pages as part of the
cart so we could say you know step one
which is basically cart we could say
step two is billing information that
could be slash billing we could see step
three is shipping information slash
shipping and then step four could be you
know confirm and that could be slash
confirmation so whatever your url
structure is for your cart and it
doesn't necessarily have to be a cart
basically all I'm doing is putting a
series of steps with URLs as each step
and why do I want to do that because I
can then track how many people go
through my funnel that I've created okay
so here I can see this is my funnel that
I've created for this particular goal
okay and the funnel is only available
for the destination URL so the funnel is
available if you want to see traffic
through the goal okay and how people go
through the funnel and where they drop
off now you have an option here to make
the first step required so if you make
that first step required then that means
you're measuring the funnel through the
first step only now if I turn that off
then I'm measuring the funnel through
each step meaning that I can measure
people as they drop in and out of the
funnel where if it's required the first
step then I'm only measuring traffic as
it enters in the top of the funnel so
you have that option available to you
the funnel and then for all goals you do
have a value so if somebody did actually
convert Okay Google analytics is going
to count it as a conversion and you can
assign a value so if you're not an
e-commerce website then you may want to
think about about assigning value if you
are an e-commerce website then analytics
has the ability to track e-commerce
revenue for your website so you don't
need to add a value but in this case
let's just say your non-profit
organization and you're collecting
donations
and on average over the past year every
donation that somebody contributed was
equal to five dollars well you can just
go ahead and put five dollars in there
as the value for that goal so that means
that if somebody did go to in this
example slash thank you and convert
analytics is going to count it as a goal
and then assign five dollar value
alongside that goal so if you're
non-ecommerce if you're say a non-profit
like this organization or your B2B and
you want to track some value then you
have that option there so with the
destination URL goal you have the option
of adding a funnel with all gold types
you have the option of adding a value
all goal types and we're going to go
through the rest of them you have the
option of verifying that goal so that's
the structure of setting up a goal
destination URL is just one goal type
we're going to talk about the other
three goal types because in Google
analytics there are four goal types
again destination is one of them with
destination as you do have the option
with all goal types is you have to be
able to choose your logic here so we're
going to cover that with the other three
but just know when you set up a
destination URL goal you have the option
of adding a funnel now when you actually
do set up a funnel what's going to
happen is analytics is going to measure
traffic as it goes to the funnel so
where do you look for that funnel
information well you want to get out of
admin you want to go to the left side
navigation you want to click on
conversions then goals then funnel
visualization So based on the funnel you
set up you're going to be able to see
traffic as it goes through the funnel so
notice on this particular funnel we
don't have the first step required why
because I could see traffic as it goes
in and out of each step of the funnel so
let's go through this funnel and see how
people react so here I could see the
first step is the store front page so
over this particular period of time I
have 84 sessions enter the storefront
page so out of those 84 I can see 21
left the storefront page 63 went on to
the next step in the funnel which is the
cart page I can then see 24 people went
on to the cart page directly and five
exited the site all together okay so
that gave me 87 total and from 87 I saw
that 82 when on to the next page for the
next step what analytics does is they
give you a percentage so in the first
step we had 63 move on to the cart page
out of 84 that's 75 percent so from the
cart page to the create your account
page we had 94 move on so we didn't have
anybody enter in the create your account
page we didn't have anybody leave to
create your account page so if 82 82
create your account and then we have 82
move on to the payment page so that's a
hundred percent okay we have one exit so
we have 81 that proceeded to beyond the
payment page which was purchased so 81
of 82 is 98
and we started with 84 so that gave us
plus the 24 that we accumulated along
the way so that gave us a 75 funnel
conversion rate so 75 percent the people
who entered in the funnel went on to
purchase okay so don't be confused with
the overall e-commerce conversion rate
so 75 is the final conversion rate the
overall conversion rate for this
particular goal is 18.45 over this
particular period of time why because
that takes into account all sessions
that have won to the website so 18 of
all traffic went on to convert but those
that did go into the final 75 converted
so that's a look at the funnel so if you
set up a funnel that's what it's going
to look like you have the option to
measure everything from step one and
Beyond or measure as traffic goes in and
out of the funnel so the purpose of this
is we're going to be able to see where
traffic drops off how effective our
funnel is what pages we need to address
in that funnel okay so that's the whole
point of the funnel and the funnel is
available with the destination URL goal
so if I go back to admin if I go back to
goals Under The View I can actually see
what that funnel looks like so here we
chose regular expression so this is what
the URL is okay you can see our funnel
in each of the steps we have set up
notice we're using regular Expressions
here and then if we verify this goal we
could see over the past seven days 19
conversion rate so that tells me
something's working in this particular
with this particular goal because we do
have a conversion rate okay so that's
the destination URL goals let's now talk
about the other three types of goals so
the next goal type we're going to talk
about is pages per session so if you're
not sure what type of goal to set up for
your website at the very least you
should try and set up either duration
related goal or pages per session
related goal so let's talk about the
pages per session so basically what this
goal is going to allow us to measure is
for example if we set the goal to three
pages per session then we're going to be
able to measure if how many people went
to the site and looked at three pages
per session so let's take a look at that
goal so if I open up the goal here I
could see three pages per session is
what we're naming it so basically what
we're asking analytics to do is anything
greater than two pages which would be
three and Beyond count as a goal so if
anybody comes to the site looks at more
than two pages three pages or more then
it's going to count as a goal and so
here we can verify it so if we verify it
over the last seven days we could see a
4.12 conversion rate and that tells me
that four percent of my traffic over the
last seven days looked at at least three
pages or more so you're probably asking
yourself well what number should I put
in for the actual variable so in this
case we see two well what you want to do
is you want to look at on average let's
just say year to day you want to make
sure you have statistical significance
so you want to look at a period of time
so if you go to analytics go to audience
okay and then if you go to overview and
if I change my date range to year to
date I could see on average right now I
have 1.21 pages per session so that's on
average
so we don't want to make our goal one
page we don't want to make our goal two
pages we want to make it three so we
want to be able to basically measure at
a higher rate okay why do we want to
measure at a higher rate because if 1.21
is the average then two pages per
session really isn't moving the needle
so what we really want to do is get
people to stay on the site longer look
at Pages more during their session so
look at more pages and so we want to be
able to see what segment of the audience
is looking at more pages what channels
driving traffic that's looking at more
pages what pages are contributing to
more pages per session so the whole idea
is you want to hone in on what your goal
is and see what's working and then see
what's not working so you can make
adjustments the whole idea be on Google
analytics is to improves website
performance and so if our average is 1.2
then if we change it to just 2 it may
not be good enough so in this case you
know we want to up the bar a little bit
so we're going to choose three now you
can choose four or five that's perfectly
fine just know if your average is 1.2 I
wouldn't choose one page per session as
my goal and I probably wouldn't choose
two so I'd set the bar a little bit
higher now the third goal type available
in Google analytics is also engagement
related and that's duration so just like
pages per session we can measure how
long somebody stays on the website and
we could set up a goal for that so in
this case I have a goal set for one
minute 30 seconds so my goal type is
duration so if I click continue then
basically I'm asking analytics in this
case anybody who stays more than one
minute and 30 seconds on the website
count it as a goal and so so before you
actually put in the number of hours
minutes and seconds you want to look at
that average so if you go back to
audience overview here I can see a
minute and seven so do we want a minute
and 30 maybe we could do that maybe we
can go with two minutes so again the
whole point is you want to set the bar a
little bit higher than what the average
is and so here I could see over the last
seven days if I verify this particular
goal I can see eight percent of my
traffic over the last seven days stayed
on the site at least one minute and 31
seconds okay they stay greater than one
minute and 30. and so the whole point is
you can hone in because this is a goal I
can go in this is goal okay this is a
goal here and so I could see that this
is gold 13. so now I can go to
acquisition as an example I can go to
channels as an example since this is I
go this is goal 13 so that would be in
goal set three so I can actually see
what channel is basically driving that
goal okay in other words what channel is
driving traffic that is staying on the
side at least one minute 30 seconds and
so that's the whole idea behind goals so
likewise for pages per session we can go
into channels and here I can see we have
a over this period of time year to date
pages per session we have three percent
conversion rate and here I could see for
example organic search has a 13
conversion rate here I could see social
media has a 10 so I could see that or
people coming from organic search are
staying on the site longer or they're
looking at more pages than any other
channel so just like duration or
destination or any goal you set up you
can measure that goal against any
Dimension just because his engagement
doesn't mean you can't you absolutely
can and so the whole point of Engagement
related goals is to figure out what's
driving traffic the site but what
traffic is engaging so you want to be
able to pinpoint that so you can improve
website performance now the fourth goal
type available in Google analytics is an
event so if you click on new goal
include custom click continue you have
the option to choose an event so an
event is something that you can measure
on your website that analytics can't
measure by default so if you want to
measure PDF downloads or clicks on
buttons or clicks on play buttons on a
video or click on a submit button or
click on an external link I mean you can
measure pretty much anything with an
event then you want to be able to turn
that event into a goal so let's quickly
summarize what an event is so again we
want to be able to measure a particular
event that happens on the website so in
order to do so we need to identify that
event so if I go to for example this
particular website here and I want to
measure how many times somebody clicks
on the Donate Now button well if I met I
can measure that as an event so when you
set up an event in analytics you have to
actually assign a category and an action
for that event so that's the first thing
you need to do when you identify an
event or let it go first you need to set
up the event in order to set up the
event you need to assign a category in
action okay so once you identify what
you want to track as an event on your
website you're actually going to go on a
tag manager or have your web Master go
on a tag manager and set up a tag and in
that tag they're going to assign that
particular category in action and so
here you can see we have this set up our
category is named donate now and our
action is click and that's what we want
to do we want to measure how many people
click on that donate Now button so
anytime somebody does that then the
category donate now is going to appear
in analytics with the action click so
when you actually do set up an event you
can go into analytics and you can test
that event so if I go to the website and
I click donate now Okay the reason why I
have this as an event is because I'm
taking to a third-party website to
handle the donations so here I can go
into analytics and now I can see a
category is being fired for header
donate with the action click so that's
my category and that's my action so that
category in action is what is firing
after somebody clicks on the Donate Now
button so if I want to turn this event
into a goal I can easily do that now
that I've set up the event now that I've
identified the category in action I want
to go back to admin and set up the event
with these parameters in place so just
turns out we already have the goal set
up so let's go through how this goal is
set up so first we chose custom we chose
event we gave it a name so has the best
practice when you actually set up a goal
as an event or turn an event into a goal
I would add the prefix event colon to it
and then that way when you're
identifying goals in your reporting you
know it's an event so I'm going to click
continue and now that I've actually have
set up the event already in Google tag
manager I giving it a category give it
an action okay see here you can see we
have a regular expression set up so
anything with the header donate or
donate is going to fire this goal so
over the last seven days of a 0.81
conversion rate okay I could have easily
put in equals two and put in whatever
the action what or the category which is
donate now or I could have put action
equals click I could have done that as
well so let me show you another example
here so if I do this custom continue
events donate now here's my goal ID it's
going to be an event so all I need to do
is put in the category in action so
donate now and then click so that's all
I have to do and that's my goal so I can
verify it okay to see if anybody's fired
it and basically that's what I need to
do to turn that event into to a goal
okay so you need to set up for an event
first you need to identify the event set
it up and Google tag manager which is
another platform and once you've done
that then you have your category in
action once you have your category in
action you're again going to go into
analytics and then simply put in that
category and action into the appropriate
fields to set up your event related goal
now all events don't have to be turned
into a goal if you actually do set up an
event and you're not worthy of a goal
meaning it's not a kpi or a dozen align
with your business goals well don't fret
you can always just go to behavior okay
you can always go to events you can
always go to overview and measure your
events that way so here you can see all
of our events that are fired now we do
have this one turn into a goal so if
it's important for a business then we
want to make sure we we convert that
particular event into a goal okay if
it's not important for example
somebody's just clicking on a social
button then you don't necessarily have
to turn that event into a goal if you
don't want to know that it's sitting
here under events under Behavior so the
point I'm trying to make here if it's
important to your business and you're
already tracking it as an event via
Google tag manager then feel free to
turn it into a goal all you need is a
category all you need is that action and
so so one final note on that event
related goal just like any other goal
you can add a value okay so if I have an
event set up I can choose to add a value
here or in Google tag manager if I've
assigned a value to that event so if I
go back to the actual event and Google
tag manager you could say I have a value
set up for one dollar then I could just
go into analytics and say you know what
I already have the value added so go
ahead and use the value added in Google
tag manager okay so I'm going to choose
yes now if I choose no I have the option
to add the value here just like I would
with any other goal so just keep that in
mind you can add a value to any goal
type with an event related goal you can
add the value right into the tag in
Google tag manager just as I've done
here so remember when you actually set
up your goals whether it's a destination
pages per session duration or an event
you can just go ahead and choose that
goal set that it's in and measure any
Dimension against that particular goal
so here I can see e newsletter sign ups
by Channel I can go into another goal
set here I can see contact form
submissions okay I can see what
particular channels driving contact form
submissions okay so just know that you
can align a goal against any Dimension
so if you have e-commerce you don't have
to set up for goal for that that's
separate but if you want to take a look
at your goals and analytics and on its
own you can just go to conversions goals
overview here I can actually get a good
sense of how my goals are performing
over a period of time so again if I
choose for example year to date now I
can see based on the goals I've set up
how many total goal completions value
which takes into account the value we've
added into these goals okay the total
conversion rate and here I can see it
broken down by the goal I actually have
set up and I can see it by Page or I
could see it by Source a medium so I
could see Google organic is driving the
most gold completions then Google CPC
direct and then I could see some others
in here as well contributing to goals
now I do want to point your attention to
another report in Google analytics that
does take into account goals and that's
multi-channel funneling so again under
conversion goals multi-channel funnels
if I go to assistant conversions I can
actually see what channel in this
example is assisting with the
conversions I've set up and so what do
we mean by assistive conversions well
that means that if a channel let's just
say organic search drove traffic to the
website and that traffic didn't convert
when it arrived at the website and left
but it came back a week later via
another Channel let's just say email and
when they came back via email they did
convert during that session well what
analytics does is they give an assist to
organic search because they help Drive
the traffic to the website so it's
similar to the game of basketball if I
have the ball and I pass it to my
colleague and my colleagues the one who
scores because they had the ball last
well they get the credit for the point
I.E the conversion but I get an assist
and so analytics works the same way
they're always going to give credit to
the last click or direct conversion but
they will give credits to the channel in
this case that assisted with the
conversion so that's under assistive
inversion and that's based on the goals
you have set up you can highlight any
particular goal here if I want to hone
in on say the Donate clicks only then
I'm going to be able to see what
contributed to that particular goal so
there's another report in here top
conversion pass that I think is
important so after you set up your goals
you can actually see what channels in
this particular example help to Drive
conversions again this is year to day so
I can see all the different combinations
of channels that work together to
contribute to a conversion so again I
can choose a specific goal or I can
choose all my goals so those two reports
are under multi-channel funneling
there's also another report that I think
is good that's time lag meaning how long
did it actually take somebody to convert
so here you can see most of our
conversions 265 year-to-date happen on
the day somebody arrived on the website
but I could say I did get some
conversions a day later two days later
Etc so you have time lag top conversion
pass assistant conversions they're all
under multi-channel funneling and
they're all available after you set up
at least one goal and so if you're not
sure what goal to set up okay don't fret
you can always at least set up an
engagement relay related goal so that's
available to you duration pages per
session you also have destination and
event tracking and they're all available
to you you have 20 available per view
now if you're not quite sure exactly
what type of goal to set up there is an
option available in analytics and that's
the gallery so you can always import a
goal from the gallery so in other words
we could take a look at what other
people have set up in terms of goals so
you just have to click on the button
import from gallery and it'll take you
to the gallery and you'll be able to see
what are the goals others have set up
today we're going to talk about how to
set up event tracking in Google
analytics so let's get started so many
of you out there have a website similar
to the one I'm looking at now this is a
non-profit that I work with I'm a
foundation and like this website and
probably like your web website you
probably have some interactivity on
there that needs to be tracked for
example buttons uh if you have buttons
like this one that says donate or
newsletter sign up or there's a PDF
download or a video that needs to be you
know tracked based on the amount of
people who click on the play button so I
mean all sorts of inter activity on a
website have you ever wondered how to
track that well there is a way to track
that because by default Google analytics
can't track interactivity and engagement
on your website like you probably want
to have your website tracked so if you
have buttons and videos and things of
that nature that you want to attract but
you're going to need event tracking and
if you're in analytics and you're always
wanting around the data and you happen
to find yourself under events well if
you want events on your website and you
want data to populate under Behavior top
event events you're going to need to set
up event tracking so event tracking is a
two-part process and we're going to talk
about that two-part process the first
part of that is to identify what you
want to track okay so if we go back to
our example website here I'm a
foundation again we noted there's a lot
to track here we gotta donate now Bob we
got a newsletter sign up we have some
social icons okay we got a donate Now
button here we got a play button here
got all sorts of interactivity you know
we got a button here that says you know
purchase tickets for an upcoming event I
can go throughout the website and find
different buttons and things to to track
let me just say this there's no shortage
of what you can track on your website
with event tracking so event tracking is
just basically in layman's terms
tracking engagement on your site because
Google analytics by default is only
going to track page view data meaning
how somebody got to your website what
page they looked at how long they stayed
on that page what page they left from
more or less they're timing how long
somebody stays on the website and what
pages they look at so there's more to a
website than just how long somebody
stayed on a page and so in this example
we want to be able to track everything
here not just the donating album but
everything because once you get the hang
of event tracking then it's very easy to
set up okay so step one identify what
you want to track okay so there's a lot
we want to track we're just going to use
one example to start off with and that's
going to be this donate Now button okay
so this donate Now button we want to
track now we have a newsletter sign up
we have Facebook and and that's fine you
could track all that but for the sake of
going through a step-by-step process
today let's just focus on the Donate Now
button what's focused on the donating
Now button then we'll come back and
start tracking these other things but
this is what we want to track to start
out with okay so step one identify what
you want to track now when it comes to
tracking events on a website you want to
identify those events so we did that by
choosing this donate Now button now once
we identify what we want to track we
need to assign two parameters for that
event so with event tracking you have
three parameters but one is actually
optional so you have two mandatory
parameters that you have to assign to
everything you want to track on your
website and that's the category and then
the action so event label or label is
the third parameter but again that's
optional okay so basically when we
identify an event on our website we want
to assign it a category and an action
okay so why do we want to assign it a
category in an action because when we're
in analytics under Behavior under events
top events we could see we have
different categories here and we have
different actions we have different
labels so if I click on any one of these
Dimensions I'm going to be able to see
some of the parameters I've entered in
for previous events I'm tracking okay so
the whole idea is you want to be able to
group different events together into a
category and assign an action and assign
a label to it that's really what you're
doing you're just grouping and
identifying the events you're trying to
track and so in this case I have this
donate Now button sitting in the header
okay in fact I have a lot of things
sitting in the header so if I wanted to
and I want to track all these buttons I
can create a category called header and
then if I track all these buttons all
these buttons can sit in that same
category if I wanted to or I can create
a separate category for each of these
buttons it's up to you how you organize
your categories because basically all
you're doing is giving a name to what
you're trying to track and the name is
equivalent to a category so in this case
the Donate Now button is very important
I'm just going to call it category
header donate now I need to give an
action to each category and so in this
case I'm just going to say click because
that's what the action is doing it's
it's somebody's taking the action of
clicking now if it's a video and it's a
play button I can assign an action of
play it's up to you whatever you name
these parameters you just need to be
organized and methodical about what you
name it that's all and so in this case
header donate and then click okay and so
that's our category in action and so
that's clearly step two so step one
identify what you want to track step two
assign a category action and or label
but remember label is optional so if I
go back into analytics here I could see
some categories and if I click on action
I can see some actions that I've named
now step three so we've identified in
Step One what we we want to track we've
assigned a category in action so step
three is going into Google tag manager
to set up the event okay so if you're
not familiar with Google tag manager
then you can easily just you know do a
Google search for Google tag manager and
basically you'll have all sorts of
information on it there's a good video
overview of tag manager here that you
can watch so tag manager basically is
what we want to use to set up event
tracking now tag managers use for a lot
of different things but the main thing
we're doing here is setting up an event
for our website and so I'm logged in to
the same email address I'm using for
analytics okay so now I'm in tag manager
and I want to set up my event for this
donate Now button so what do I need to
do well forever every event I want to
set up I need to set up a tag okay so if
I go to tags I can see I already have
some tags set up and some of these are
events and so when you actually set up a
tag I recommend having a naming
convention so here you can see any event
we set up we start out by calling it GA
Dash event Dash whatever it is we're
trying to set up and so in this case we
want to set up a new tag for the Donate
Now button on our website so we're in
Google tag manager because tag manager
is what's going to fire that event so if
I click on new okay and I click on tag
configuration I'm going to choose Google
analytics and then I'm going to choose
events as my track type so we want the
data to show up in Google analytics and
we're tracking an event we're not
tracking a page we're tracking an event
and so now remember in step two you
identified what you want to call that
category you identify what you want to
call that action chin and you have some
optional parameters like label so first
things first header donates the name of
our category and our action is click and
if you want to add in a label and a
value so if you want to sign a value you
can if you want to add in a label you
can okay those are optional so you just
need to focus on category in action and
then the last setting here that's
probably worth mentioning is a
non-interaction hit okay so this is
automatically set to false and why is it
set to false because it's a
non-interaction no that's false we want
this event if somebody clicks on the
header donate to be an interaction so
for example if I land on this page here
and I click on that donate Now button
that I'm tracking as an event and I
actually leave the site because I have
my settings set to false I want that
click to be an interaction then
analytics is not going to count a bounce
if I change it to true so from false to
true then that means it is going to be a
non-interaction if somebody lands on the
page and if somebody clicks on the
button so I don't want it to be a bounce
I want it to be an interaction so my
advice is leave it set to false we're
going to choose Google analytics as our
setting here this is our variable for
Google analytics so in other words that
variable is set to our analytics
property ID and more or less that's what
you need to do to set up the tag okay
you need to in step two identify the
category in action and or label and or
value now value can be anything you want
you're assigning a numerical value so if
you just assign one anytime that event
fires in analytics it's going to have a
value of one okay and so we have our
non-interaction set to false so anytime
the event fires it's going to count as
an interaction and therefore not count
as a bounce if somebody landed on that
page so that's more or less all you need
to do to set up the tag and Google tag
manager now if somebody else is setting
up the tag for you then again you want
to revert to step two you want to be
able to give that person the appropriate
category action and or label and or
value why because you're the one that's
going to be going into Google analytics
and you're the one that's going to have
to go to behavior events top events and
look for the particular at category in
action and or label so you need to be
able to communicate that information to
whomever is setting up the tag now if
it's you great you already know what it
is because you're entering that
information into tag manager so in this
case I'm going to go ahead and choose a
variable for my label parameter and why
do I want to do that because in tag
manager I have something at my disposal
called variables and variables allow you
to see specifically things that are
being tracked so in this case I chose
pagepath okay so pagepath is a URL and
why did I choose page path as my
variable for the parameter label because
if somebody does click on the header
donate button and the header donate
button on our website is on every page
so if I go to the children's page I'm
still going to see that header donate
button and so for me I want to be able
to see what page somebody clicked on
that hitter donate button and so this
allows me to actually see in Google
analytics what page somebody clicked on
the header donate Now button and so now
if I go back to GTM Google tag manager I
have a category I have an action and I
have a label which is a variable okay so
note that in Google tag manager you have
a lot of different variables at your
disposal and variables are there to help
you identify specifically what is being
tracked so take a look at all the
variables at your disposal and tag
manager in this example I'm using page
path so now once you set up your tag
pretty straightforward again tag types
Google analytics track type is event you
are assigning the category action and or
label and or value you're changing or
leaving the default in place for
non-interaction hit and then you're
choosing the variable for Google
analytics which is your property ID so
once you've done that you have a tag the
second part of setting up a tag is to
assign a trigger to that tag so tag
manager needs to be able to know when to
fire that event and so here I'm going to
look at a trigger I've already set up
for the this particular event and so if
I click on it I'll be able to see that
what it is it's a click on some links
not all links but some links I'm
actually saying Hey Google tag manager
fire this event when the click ID equals
header donate button now it just so
happens that if somebody did click on
this donate Now button they're gonna go
to another website in this case
networkforgood.com so in tag manager I
could have set the trigger to equal URL
equal instead of Click ID I could have
said URL equal
networkforgood.com so that could have
been my Logic for my trigger in this
case I decided to go with the click ID
and so in this case that button has an
ID associated with it called header
donate button so if you wanted to use
click ID for your event for your button
you could simply just go to the website
you can right click on that button and
click inspect element and so when I
actually inspect the element I can see
now the button here you can see it's
highlighted in the upper Pane and in the
lower pane I can see where it's linking
to it's linking to networkforgood.com
but here you can see if I hone in a
little it I could see ID equals header
Dash donate dash button so that's the
click ID notice there's also a class I
could have set the trigger to equal this
class or again I could have set the
trigger to equal the URL or the page
that this button is pointing to I could
have chosen any one of those but I
decided to go with the ID so this is the
ID I chose and that's the ID I have in
my trigger okay so that is what's going
to fire that event so if somebody clicks
on a button that equals header Dash
donate dash button it's going to fire
that event which is going to equal
category header donate action click and
then the label is going to be page path
so now that we've set up our event we
want to test to see if it actually works
so there's two ways to go about testing
an event and the first way is through
Google analytics so if we go to Google
analytics and then we go to real time
okay we can go to events and here you
can see one is already fired so let's go
ahead and go to and test this and go to
the website so if I go here for example
and I click on omagar alumni okay so if
I click on that you can see I'm under
our family and if I click on that button
then go back to analytics and look at
real time I should be able to see this
event fire so if I click on it I'm going
to go to network for good now if I go
back to analytics here in real time
under real time under events per second
I can see that event firing category
equals header donate the action equals
click now if I click on the category
here I can see the label the label
remember was page path and here you can
see this event fired on the our family
page which was the page I was just on so
that's one way to test to see if your
event works and in this case analytics
recognize the event so it works it fired
and so therefore it's going to show up
under Behavior under events you can go
under overview or top events okay and
what am I going to look for in this case
I'm going to look for header donate okay
if I click on head or donate as my
category I'm going to be able to see my
action and if I click on action I'll be
able to see my label in this case home
page and then later on when the data
propagates in analytics I'll be able to
see under label the page that I clicked
on that header donate button which is
slash our family okay the second way in
which you can test to see if an event
fires is if you preview so if I click on
preview in tag manager okay I'm going to
go into preview mode okay in preview
mode allows you to see in analytics and
tag manager and on the website what tags
are firing so here I could see I'm in
preview mode now so I'm going to go to
the website and I'm going to refresh and
in my browser same browser I'm using for
tag manager I can see the tags that are
being fired on this page already okay
because I'm in preview mode so here I
could see remarketing I could see page
views I could see Google optimize I
could see some tags that are already
firing on this page now if I click on
this button here by holding down my
shift command and then click on that
button I'll be able to see that the tag
fired in preview mode there's my event
header donate and I can see it fired so
now I can see it fired in the preview
mode so in addition to Google analytics
in preview mode I could see that that
tag is fired and I know that it's
working so there you have it you have
two ways to test to see if the event
fires again you have real time in
analytics okay so in real time if you
just go up to real time all you need to
do is go down to events go to your
website click on the button if you see
it firing in real time then you know it
works the second version or second way
to test your event is through the
preview mode okay if you see it firing
in preview mode then you know it's also
working okay so let's rehash our steps
first step is we want to be able to
identify what we want to track okay so
it could be this newsletter sign up it
could be click on a Facebook it could be
anything we want to be able to track an
image a click on a CTA button whatever
we want to track identify it second step
identify the category action and label
because that's what's going to show up
in Google analytics remember label is
optional variable or excuse me value is
optional third step go into tag manager
actually set up your tag and your
trigger so if you set up a tag and it's
an event name it GA Dash events that way
you can see in your list of tags and tag
manager what event tracking you have
already set up so when you set up your
tag you set up your trigger your trigger
is based on logic that can be a URL it
can be a click ID it can be a class ID
whatever you want to use to fire that
event and then once you do that you want
to test it you could test it in GTM or
you could test it in Google analytics if
it doesn't fire you want to tweak your
trigger if it does fire then great and
then one thing I would recommend is if
you're setting up various events for
your website as a best practice what I
would recommend is set up a spreadsheet
and in that spreadsheet you know you
want to put a note what's firing what
are you doing to fire it could be in
this case someone somebody clicks on the
Donate Now button in the header you want
to put the tag name in here the type
okay then you want to record your
category action and label and then the
great thing about events is you could
turn those events into goals and that's
as simple as going back into analytics
okay so if I go in analytics and I go to
admin and I go to go goals if you set up
a new goal okay all you need to do is
choose custom click continue you're
going to choose event as your goal name
and then from a naming perspective in
Google analytics for your goal I would
definitely put event first and then
click on header donate okay so if I
click now continue what is my category
it's equal to head or donate my action
is click and so I can verify to see if
this is working and here I can see in
analytics that the goal would have a
0.22 conversion rate so that tells me
that the goal is working and I can turn
this event into a goal and when you turn
something into a goal in analytics then
you can measure it across all dimensions
that's what I would recommend if the
event is equal to a kpi or business goal
or it's of importance something you
really want to measure okay it's just a
click say on a Facebook button I
wouldn't recommend setting that up as a
goal okay so once you've set up your
event you recorded it in your
spreadsheet it's firing you want to be
able to then go back into Behavior back
into events okay you can go to top
events okay so top events tell you by
category as a default what events are
firing or what category is firing the
most okay so if I choose my date range
here I can just go to here to date so
here I can see my enter donate button
fortunately for me has the most total
events now notice in analytics you also
see unique events and so the difference
between unique events and total events
is that unique events are equivalent to
one per session where total events means
that somebody can come to your website
initiate a session and click on that
button multiple times in the same same
session so if I go to the Yama
Foundation website okay I can click on
that donate Now button three or four or
five different times in the same session
so what analytics is going to do is
actually in that session count it once
but accumulate the number of clicks as a
total event for that session so you're
always going to have more total events
than unique events because in some cases
users May click on the button more than
once in the same session and so here I
can see total events unique events and
if I added a value to that event I
should be able to see it here so if I
added a dollar as an example to this
particular event because it had 164
unique events I should be able to see
164 as my value but since I see Zero
that means that I did not assign value
and so average value basically is just
giving me how much average I have per
event so it's taking into account the
number of or the value the total value
divided by the total number of unique
page views or sessions and so because I
don't have value I'm not going to have
average value but here you can see
because value is optional here I can at
least see how many events or how many
clicks I receive for a particular button
again it could be a video if I clicked
on this video as an example I can see
how many people actually started it I
could see the unique in the total events
and if I click on label if I have a
label assigned then I'll be able to see
what page triggered that event so if we
go back again to our header donate
button back to category if we click on
label as our primary Dimension here we
can see the home page had the most
unique events been followed by the
children's page the contact form Etc so
what you you can do in analytics you can
also look at the pages that have driven
events so here I could see the home page
has accumulated the most total events
followed by the contact us so that's how
you would look at the data in Google
analytics under Behavior under events
and then under top events or overview is
where you can start analyzing your event
tracking so first you need to do
identify it assign a category action
enter label set up that tag and Trigger
once you do that once you test that it's
working this is where you're gonna go to
analyze Sim lands post graduate program
and digital marketing is the right
choice for you to upskill and learn all
the Google analytics techniques so hurry
up and find the course Link in the
description box for more details so
simply learn has a new program a new
certificate for digital marketing
together with Purdue with meta and it
takes you through all the courses and
all the topics of digital marketing that
are relevant for you it sets you up for
Facebook's digital marketing exam where
you learn everything about Facebook
advertising managing your Facebook page
so it's a very useful program that I can
highly recommend you you sign up for so
click on the link to the website you'll
find a link in the description of the
video below and check it out have a look
we can highly recommend this course to
you so without further Ado let's get
started the famous Google tag manager
you might have heard of it before you
might be asking yourself right now what
is the heck is Google tag manager well
let me tell you it's a tool that will
make your life as a marketeer a lot
easier it's a free tool from Google that
lets you manage and deploy marketing and
analytics tags or Snippets of code on
your website or on your mobile app
without having to edit this code those
tags trigger events like tracking all
user interaction on your website it's
like having a personal assistant to help
you with the technical stuff so you can
focus on the creative side of things the
tool was introduced by Google in 2012
and since then it has become one of the
most widely used tag Management systems
online you might be wondering now what
are the texts don't worry about it we'll
cover that in the next slide but in
short Google tag manager helps you
simplify the process of managing tags
and tracking using user behavior on your
website
it's user-friendly and efficient tool
and it saves you a lot of time plus who
doesn't like a free tool that makes your
life easier but before we dive into the
world of Google tag manager yeah let's
talk a bit more about what the this
video will cover so in this session
we'll cover a variety of topics related
to Google tag manager first we'll
discuss what Google texts are and how
they work we'll then move on to what
Google tag manager is and how it can
help you manage your website tags more
efficiently then we'll talk about why
you need Google tag manager we'll
compare Google tag manager with Google
analytics and we'll discuss the benefits
of using Google tag manager over other
tag Management Solutions we'll then go
over how to set up Google tag managers
step by step I'll give you a short demo
so we'll make sure you have all the
information
that you need to be successful with
Google tag manager and finally I'll give
you some tips and tricks for using
Google tag manager more efficiently from
naming conventions to Version Control
we'll share some of the best practices
that can save you tons of time and
headaches in the long run
and then by the end of this video you
should have a solid understanding of
Google tag manager and how it can
benefit you and your website so before
we dive into the specifics of the
platform let's take a moment to discuss
Google Tags so what are they well simply
put their Snippets of code that allows
you to track various actions and data on
your website they're like little spies
they keep an eye on what your visitors
are doing and they report it back to you
for example you can use Google Tags to
track when someone clicks on a specific
button on your website or how long they
stay on a particular page or even if
they abandon their shopping cart
then this information can be used to
improve your website and your marketing
efforts so without tax you'll be Flying
Blind when it comes to understanding how
people are interacting with your website
but with Google Tags you'll have a
wealth of information and data at your
fingertips
so let's then move on to Google tag
manager Google tags are codes of snippet
created by Google tags that are designed
to work with various Google tools like
analytics like Google ads they allow you
to track user interactions such as
clicks page views and many more type of
an interactions they're code Snippets
that are small pieces of code that you
can add to your website to track user
behavior and gather important data so
the beauty of these tags is that you
don't need to be a coding expert to use
them with Google tag manager you can
easily add modify and remove those tags
without having to touch the code on your
website you don't have to be a developer
to do this so if you're a marketeer or a
data analyst or just someone who is
interested in understanding how people
interact with your website these little
Snappers of code can provide a lot of
valuable insights but make sure you're
using them correctly and always test
your tags before publishing them to your
live website Google tags are not only
Snippets of code but they are also used
for tracking purposes they allow you to
track specific events on your websites
like clicks on a button or form
submissions or video plays you can also
track how users interact with your
website like how long they stay on the
page what pages they visit how deep do
they scroll on the page and by tracking
this user Behavior you can gain
fantastic insights in how users engage
with your website and this can help you
in optimizing your website as well to
improve the user experience for example
if you notice that many people are
abandoning the shopping cart you can use
Google Tags to track the point where
they leave the card and adjust your
website design or Mark marketing
strategy accordingly Google Tags and not
a very important function of them is
that you can use them for remarketing
which means that you can Target users
who have already interacted with your
website with a personalized ads this can
help increase conversions and customer
retention so when somebody visits your
website it will trigger the tag yep and
then it will activate the ad in Google
ads or in Facebook ads and then people
will that that person that visited your
website will then receive and
personalized ads so in short Google text
they do not only provide important data
on user Behavior but can also you can
use it to use the data to improve your
website and improve your marketing
efforts so very important in Google tag
manager are also the containers yes so
there are you use containers in Google
tag manager so what are containers think
of them as the holding area for your tag
you can create multiple containers for
different website sections or even for
individual Pages yeah now let's dive a
bit deeper into the most huge tags in
Google tag manager the first one is the
Google analytics tag yeah which is used
to track the website traffic and
behavior so when you want to track your
websites and analytics by Google you
have to add a tag on every page of your
website
and when people visit that page that
will trigger Google analytics that it
will track that interaction on your
website
not a very popular tank is the Facebook
pixel tag which helps track convergence
from Facebook ads the third tag that's
commonly used is the AdWords conversion
tracking tag which is used to track
conversions from Google AdWords
campaigns and fourth there is for
instance the hot jar tag which is used
for website heat mapping and user
Behavior Analysis finally there is also
the Google optimization tag which is
used for a b testing and for
personalization these are just a few of
the many tags available in Google tag
manager but they're definitely the most
commonly used ones so now that you know
what containers are in the most used
tags in Google tag manager you should be
able to start creating your own tags and
your own containers so let's get into
the details here let's look at how you
manage your tags using Google tag
manager so Google tag manager is a
powerful tool that allows you to manage
all your website tags in one place
without having to code anything on your
website you don't have to get into the
code of your website you don't have to
add any code for you on your website
Google tag manager will do that gone are
those days that you have to ask your
developer to add tracking codes to your
website or landing pages with Google tag
manager you can do it yourself you can
easily add modify and deploy tags to
your website without any technical
knowledge so with Google tag manager or
GTM as people call it you can manage
tags for all kinds of purposes such as
tracking remarketing conversion tracking
and you can also create triggers that
determine when and where the tags are
fired on your website so GTM is made to
make your life easier and with the help
of this tool you'll be able to
streamline your digital marketing
efforts when when it comes to tracking
your website performance and make
marketing data traffic and make data
driven decisions to help grow your
business so let's dive in and explore
the world of Google tag manager so
Google tag manager is like a superhero
it saves the day and it helps you manage
all the tags on your website it's free
yeah it's from Google and it helps you
simplify that process of adding and
managing multiple tracking tags and
we've gone through those tags here like
Google analytics Facebook analytics and
you don't need a developer to get
involved
the beauty about GTM is that it provides
an intuitive interface that lets you set
up test and deploy the tags quickly so
you can focus on optimizing your website
without having to worry about managing
those code Snippets with GTM you can
also easily update your tags easy add
new ones or remove old ones all in one
central location
yeah so think of GTM of the conductor of
a well orchestrated band it brings all
your tracking tags together and ensures
they play in harmony so you can hear a
beautiful Melody of Data Insights
so summing up Google tag manager is like
having a personal assistant for your
website taking care of all the tracking
tags so you can focus on what really
matters and that is making your website
look awesome and work awesome for you
one of the biggest benefits of Google
tag manager's interface is that it
allows you to manage all your tags in
one place
yeah so that means no more searching
through the lines of code to find that
one tag that causes the issue on your
site with GTM you can just easily add
edit or remove tags
but there's more the GTM interface also
offers a preview mode so you can test
your tags before they go live yeah and
let's not forget about the custom
variables and the triggers that you can
use with GTM you can set up variables to
track specific user behavior and create
triggers to fire tags based on those
actions it's like having your own spy
Network tracking every move your users
make on your website yeah so Google
stack manager interface is like having a
trusty sidekick that takes care of all
your tagging needs
easy to use it offers a preview mode and
allows you to create custom variables
and triggers so then why do I need
Google tag manager well let's face it
websites today are loaded with all kind
of tags from tracking codes to
conversion pickles and it can be a
hassle to manage all of those yet not to
mention the headache you have to go
through and manage to wait for your web
developer to make even the slightest
this is where Google tag manager comes
in to save your day yeah with Google tag
manager you have complete control over
all your tags without having to rely on
a developer it also allows you to easily
set up the tracking and conversion
events plus it makes it easy to test and
debug your tests before Dogo day go live
yep and let's not forget about time
saving benefits of GTM yeah with
everything in one place you can stream
your online your workflow and get more
done in last time so adding tracking
codes as we know can be a headache yep
certainly
you don't want those headaches and
that's why Google tag manager comes in
it provides these user-friendly
interface to easily manage all of your
tracking codes in one place not only
does it make managing those codes easier
but it also saves time and eliminates
the need for technical expertise you
don't have to be a computer wizard to
use Google tag manager with it you can
easily add edit and remove tracking
codes with just a few clicks plus it
allows for greater customization and
flexibility and that will give you
better insights and therefore better
decision making so why do we need Google
tag manager to simplify Our Lives Save
times and make managing tracking codes a
lot easier
trust me once you start using it you
won't know how you ever lived without it
managing tags as I said clearly it can
be like juggling to keep track of all
the different balls and make sure that
they don't drop now with Google tag
manager it's like having an assistant
who's an expert juggler
without it as I told you before it can
be a real headache you have to go into
the goat of each individual page and add
or remove those tags manually and if you
have a lot of text I tell you that could
be a lot of code that you have to shift
through
but again with GTM you can manage all
your tags in one place and easily add or
remove them without having to touch the
code on your website
so if you have multiple tags that you
need to keep track of on your website
GTM is a must it simplifies the process
and helps ensure that your tags are
implemented correctly and efficiently
and thereby you have more time to work
on those things that really matter
so another key benefit is how easy it
makes updating those tags on your
website again you don't rely on
developers to add and remove tracking
codes you don't lose time with it you
have full control over all your tags
allowing you to add them quickly
modified or remove them whenever you
need to think of it like a magic wand
for your website's tracking no more
waiting for someone else to do it for
you you're in the driver's seat now plus
with the intuitive interface of GTM it's
so easy to do even if you're not a
coding with it
so you can easily fix errors and typos
in your text without having to wait for
the developer to do this it's like
having a safety net to your website's
tracking ensuring that your data is
always accurate and up to date
yes so if you want to take control of
your website's tracking then Google
manager is Google tag manager is
absolutely a must another reason why you
need Google tag manager is that it
allows you to easily manage multiple
tags from different sources like Google
analytics like AdWords and even
third-party tags so you no longer have
to to worry about missing out on
valuable data because you can now keep
track of all those different tracking
codes
but it also allows you to prioritize and
organize those tags so you can ensure
that the most important ones are firing
correctly and in the right area order
and with the built-in error checking and
debugging tools and we'll talk about
that later you can quickly identify and
fix issues as soon as they come up
so with Google tag manager you can make
updates to your text without having to
touch the code so that gives you so much
extra time you win a lot of time where
you can focus on those things that
really matter so let's talk about the
difference between Google tag manager
and Google analytics yes Google
analytics is a powerful tool that helps
you analyze your website's traffic the
user Behavior and the performance of
your website it's like that agent that
gathers information on your website
visitors on the other hand Google tag
manager is like the secret agent's
assistant
it helps manage and deploy all the
tracking codes or tags on your website
think of it like a personal assistant
who takes care of all the tedious tasks
so the main agent Google analytics in
this case can focus on the important
stuff
well both tools are important to your
website success they do serve different
purposes
Google analytics gives you insight into
your website's performance while GTM
helps you manage and organize the
tracking codes that feed into Google
analytics in other words Google
analytics is like the captain of the
ship navigating the orders while GTM is
the Navigator who helps guide to Captain
and make sure everything is running
smoothly
so whether you're an analytics expert or
an office knowing the difference between
these two tools will help you better
understand how to optimize your
website's performance yeah so let me
explain this in a bit more detail yeah
so if you're using Google analytics you
know what it means when you feel like
you're drowning in data
well that's because GA is a very
powerful Analytics tool but it doesn't
come with any tag management
capabilities and that's where GTM comes
in GTM and Google analytics may seem
similar at first but they serve
different purposes
GA helps you track and analyze your
website traffic while GTM helps you
manage tracking your tags
it's like GA is the map that tells you
where you are and GTM is the compass
that helps you navigate to where you
want to go
without GTM you have to manually add a
tracking tags to your website code every
time you want to track a new event or
behavior that's like trying to build a
car with your bare hands instead of
using tools
GTM simplifies the process by letting
you add and manage tags through a
user-friendly interface
so while GA is great for analyzing data
it is not equipped to handle tag
management that's why GTM is a necessary
tool for any website owner or marketeer
looking to streamline their tracking
efforts now that we understand the basic
differences between GTM and Google
analytics let's talk about one of the
most important aspect of these tools
data collection
Google analytics is primarily designed
to collect and analyze website traffic
data it helps you understand things like
where your visitors are coming from
which pages are most popular and how
long people are spending on your site
on the other hand GTM is focused on
collecting data about specific actions
or events on your website like a form
submission or a button click it allows
you to track these interactions and
create custom tags that trigger based on
the data collected
think of it this way if Google analytics
is a map of the traffic flow of your
website GTM is the traffic light that
helps you control and manage that flow
by using GTM to manage your tags and
tracking you can get more granular
insights into behavior of your users and
optimize your website accordingly and
since GTM is designed to work seamlessly
with Google analytics you can easily
combine the insights from both tools to
get a complete picture of your website's
performance yep so whether you're a
marketeer or a developer using both GTM
and Google analytics can help you make
data-driven decisions and improve your
website's overall effectiveness so
another important difference is that way
the tools report on the data and how
they visualize the data
yes so you'll be happy to know that
Google analytics of course has some very
Nifty visualization tools
with Google analytics you can create
custom dashboards and reports that show
your website data in all sorts of fancy
ways if you want a graph that shows the
number of people who visited your
website from a specific country Google
analytics can do that if you want to do
in a pie chart that shows the breakdown
of traffic sources Google analytics can
do that but Google tag manager doesn't
offer any visualization tools while it
does offer is the ability to collect
data and send it to Google analytics
where you can then turn it in charge and
graphs while GTM may not have the eye
candy that GA has it has to be how it is
to behind the scenes Workhorse that
makes it all possible
think of GTM as the stage crew of a
Broadway show they may not be in the
spotlight but without them the whole
production falls apart so when it comes
to user friendliness GTM and Google
analytics couldn't be more different GTM
is like your fun easy going friend who's
always up for a good time while GA is
like your uptight neighbor who complains
about your music being too loud
gtm's interface is designed with the
user in mind making it easy to navigate
and understand you don't need to be a
coding genius to use it in fact you
don't even need to know how to code it
all plus its drag and drop functionality
makes adding and managing tax a breeze
now on the other hand GA is a bit of a
dinosaur it's a bit more complex and it
can take time getting used to it's like
trying to assemble a piece of furniture
without any instructions it may take you
a while to figure it out and you mind up
end up with some extra pieces you don't
know what you do with it so overall
gtm's user-friendly interface makes it a
clear winner in this category
with GTM you can spend less time
struggling with a difficult interface
and more time analyzing your data and
making informed decisions
so when it comes to pricing Google tag
manager and Google analytics have
different approaches
Google analytics has a free version
available to everyone which is good news
particularly when you just start out and
when you don't have a large budget
however there's some some limitations in
the free version and that may not be
sufficient for more complex businesses
but they can also upgrade to a premium
version of Google Analytics
on the other hand Google tag manager
offers a free version as well as a paid
version that often the paid version
offers more advanced features and
Integrations the pricing for the paid
version is based on the number of
monthly sessions your website has
so which one is better for your business
it really depends on your needs and
budgets if you're just starting out to
have a smaller website Google analytics
might be the way to go but if you have a
larger website or need more advanced
features the paid version of Google tag
manager might be worth the investment
now remember the best way to determine
which tool is right for you is to
evaluate your business needs and your
budget carefully and make the right
decisions accordingly
right so let's have a look at how you
set up Google tech manager let's dig in
and let me give you a demo of how to use
Google tag manager right so here we are
on Google tag manager and this is the
screen where you will have a list of
your accounts now here is a an empty
account I've only created tubemark 01
and there's no tags on these there is
nothing on this so this is how you will
find your tag manager when you sign in
or sign up with your Google account yeah
so the first thing you're going to do is
to create an account and I've created
account already which is tube mark01 if
you want to create another account you
just click on create account you say
what is your account name what is the
country do you want to share data with
Google anonymously what is the container
name that could be the website right for
instance yeah but if you don't put a
container setup immediately yeah then
you just click create and then you will
have another account under this but
we're sticking for the demo purposes
with tube Mark 01 so here I'm going to
click to create a container which I
could have done as well when I created
the account but let's for Simplicity
purposes let's click here create a
container and then it's going to ask the
same questions the credit or the website
is in my case react
for russia.com
there we go and it's going to be for the
web it could be for iOS it could be for
Android for Accelerated mobile Pages or
for server-side instrumentation what
have you but the most obvious one is for
your web so you could also set tax for
your apps yep so on either iOS or
Android but let's focus on the web and
then you just click create as simple as
that and that will set you up for Google
tag manager set up for react for
russia.com in my case now here you see a
piece of code so you need to tell every
web page on your website that it is
ready to accept tags from Google tag
manager which means that there will be a
piece of code that has to be installed
on every page yeah so you paste this
code in the header and you paste this
immediately after the opening body tag
now what you will see here is that there
is still that there are the the CMS
systems to content Management Systems
like WordPress and many others as well
they have plugins that you can can get
to actually install the code for you now
you then don't actually have to install
the code but what you need to enter in
the plugin is basically this number yeah
if I click on here it takes me to that
same page of code but I don't have to do
that when I use a plugin in for instance
WordPress so I just copy and paste this
number and then Google
um will connect with WordPress and the
tag manager will be set up for the
website because otherwise of course I
would be able to put a tank on every
website out there so there need to be
some sort of a verification so you go
into the backend system of your CMS you
get a plugin for Google tag manager and
then you enter this number then
WordPress will connect with Google tag
manager create a link and then you know
read Furniture is yours and then you can
start using the tag manager now here you
see the interface it's very
straightforward you have your overview
of your tags you have the tags
themselves the triggers remember we
talked about that in the earlier
sections the variables you can create
folders and here is a list of templates
all the things that we talked about in
the in the earlier presentation here you
can have your version control and here
you have your admin where you can manage
users for instance and the admin rights
or the viewing rights yeah that they
they have so here you have if you want
to create a new tag here you see what
you are editing at the moment here you
see changes that have not been published
remember we talked about a preview mode
as well you can activate that here then
if you're happy with your tag then you
click the submit button Google tag
manager will then connect with your
website and the tags will installed so
each tag comes with triggers yeah so
because obviously the tag that you put
on the pages of your website they need
to be triggered by something that could
be a page view it could be a filling in
a form watching a video and what have
you so let's go and create a tag there
are two ways to create a tag I can go
here on new tag or I can go here on tags
yep so let's just click here create a
new tag so that takes me to the page
where I can create my tag and there is
the name of the tag that is Riyadh demo
if I can also put it in a folder and
then you will see for each tag setup
there is a configuration and there is to
trigger so the trigger is the event that
takes place when you want uh what you
when you want to trigger the the tag
coach yes so let's click here on choose
attack type and here you have a whole
library of templates of tags that have
already been created so there is for
instance the Google and analytics tag
there is the standard Universal
analytics and there is the Google
analytics 4 configuration and be aware
that by July 2023 Universal analytics
will stop tracking data so you will all
have to go to the protruder process to
set up the Google analytics 4 tag on
your website
if you don't have a template yeah I
remember you saw the template here on
the left menu on your dashboard as well
you can then just add the custom HTML
code for instance if you get a tag from
Facebook the show called Facebook pixel
for retargeting you would do that
through the custom HTML but let me first
Go and show you let's say the Google
analytics 4 configuration so very
straightforward here is the tag so I
don't have to worry about that that has
to the tag coach the only thing I need
to do is put in my Google analytics
measurement ID that is an ID that I get
in Google analytics so tag manager will
know which analytics to connect to so
let's say I'm just for demo purposes to
a random number one two three four five
six yeah so now that we've set this up
we now need to define the trigger so the
trigger is what will trigger the
tag yeah what event will trigger the
tank and there's a whole range of
triggers that you can specify for this
purpose you just want the old Pages
trigger yeah so we want this code to be
installed on every page of the website
and we want to trigger the tag when
somebody views that page when somebody
then views that page it triggers the tag
the tag will connect with Google
analytics and Google will then do the
data collection of that particular page
that is as simple as it is so I click
save
and now this tag has been saved here
under react demo
as simple as that is so here I see the
tags and I now have one tag here for
Google analytics so now what I can do I
can actually preview the tag
but because I haven't connected my read
for Russia account to this particular
tag account yeah I can't show it but
when you could click on the preview it
will debug the tag as it were it will
connect with your website and then it
will test if the tag is working when
you're happy with it when it is working
you then click submit and then the tag
will be added to every page on your
website so that's basically the essence
how Google tag manager works so here you
can have an overview of the triggers and
you can create triggers yeah so I can
click the new button to create a trigger
choose a trigger type to begin the setup
and here you see a whole range of
triggers that you can use
that for a trigger setup so it could be
a page view it could be a window loaded
it could be an element visibility or a
form submission I like to scroll that so
if somebody Scrolls more than
[Music]
um
60 or 70 percent of the page that could
be a trigger when somebody watches the
YouTube video
Etc so lots of different triggers that
you can specify and add to your tag so
that is one thing the other thing that
we talked about in the presentation as
well are the variables yep so here you
see the different variables these are
the built-in variables they're available
for many of the most commonly used tag
and Trigger configurations yeah so they
can be used just like user defined
variables or you can create your new
your own user-defined variables yeah so
variable configuration that's where you
can specify URL you can have page
variables page elements or utilities so
different things that you can specify
here yeah on the variables for your for
your for your for your tags and for the
triggers yep so and there's more
variable types in the community template
Gallery yep so those are your variables
and we already talked about the template
so that is basically all there is to
using Google tag manager so you create
an account in the account you create a
container and the container takes you to
your workspace and in the workspace you
create tags
yep and then in attack you combine a tag
with a trigger then you can test it and
when you're happy with it you click
submit and then the tag will be added to
the website now
to check if the tag has been added to
the website there is a really useful
tool that Google has available and that
is the tag assistant Legacy by Google it
is a chrome plugin and you will see in
the
um the the description of the video
below the video then simply learn will
have giving will give you the link to
download the tag assistant Legacy
basically how does that work if you go
to a website let's say simplylearn.com
what I then do I activate I enable the
Google tag assistant Legacy I'm doing
then a refresh of the page and then you
see here the tags that have been set up
on this page there is the global site
tag there is to Google analytics tag and
there is the Google tag manager and
there are some more there is a Google
ads remarketing tag which is not
operational at the moment yep so green
means there is a potential issue blue is
that it's okay red is it's not working
yes so that's what you can check for uh
for Google so really useful tool that
you can use there's also a similar tool
for Facebook if you want to check the
Facebook
tags on this page you can go and there's
the Facebook metapixel helper you will
find a link to this in the description
of the video as well and you can get it
on the Chrome Store these are free
plugins you just click on it yep and
then here you see there is the metapixel
yeah for page view for view content and
there's one pixel found on the website
yes so that is how you can do that now
how would you do the page the Facebook
pixel yeah as I mentioned earlier you go
to your workspace
yeah you're going to add a new tag
and you will see that the tag type you
don't see the Facebook pixel in here so
what you do is you go to custom HTML and
the only thing you have to do here is
paste
the
Facebook
pixel
[Music]
HTML codes
that you get on the Facebook
business manager yeah so when you set up
your advertising you can set up
retargeting and they when you set it up
properly you're getting your piece of
HTML codes and you just paste that here
okay and then when you're happy with
that you call here the Facebook
pixel
yep so you have you've pasted the code
you click save I need to select a
trigger of course yes I'm going to add a
trigger the trigger is Page views
all pages I can specify specific Pages
as well yeah and then I just click save
of course it hasn't got the code here
but now I have two tags on my
um on my workspace yep and then I can
preview it see if it works and if it
works I click submit and we're up and
running
okay that concludes the demo of Google
tag manager so let's go back to the
slides and let's close the presentation
with some tips and tricks so now that
you know how to use Google tech manager
let's close today's videos with some
tips and tricks for GT my first tip to
you is to use naming conventions yeah
they are very important and they help
keep your tags triggers and variables
organized and easy to manage
in a naming convention you should
consider the context and purpose of each
component such as the prefix indicating
the type of tag or trigger followed by a
descriptive name
a clear and consistent naming convention
streamlines to tracking and helps with
the maintenance and the scalability of
your GTM implementation
second tip I can give you is to make
sure that you test your tags before the
deployment one of the key features of GT
MST ability to test your tags
before they go live yeah you can use the
preview feature in GTM it allows you to
simulate a visitor's behavior on your
website and see how tags will fire in
real time you could also use the debug
mode to see more detailed information on
how the tags are firing and any errors
that may be occurring
it is important to test your tanks
before deployment to make sure that they
are working properly and capture the
data that you need it will help you
avoid making costly mistakes and ensure
that your data is accurate and reliable
Yeah by testing your tax before they go
live you can also identify and fix any
issues before they impact your website's
performance or use your experience the
next tip I can give you is to use the
preview modes
yeah Google tag managers preview mode is
a very powerful feature that allows you
to test your website tracking and tags
before publishing them
it lets you see how your tax fire how
the data is collected and that helps you
to identify issues before you go live
so with preview mode you can simulate a
firing of tax based on user interactions
and test how your tags behaved in
various scenarios
preview mode is an essential tool to
ensure that you're tracking and your
tags are working as they are supposed to
do it gives you the confidence in your
data collection and the analysis now the
next tip is the data layer functionality
in Google tag manager yeah using a data
layer in Google tag manager allows you
to store and access data about your
website or app that can be used by tags
triggers and variables
it's a JavaScript object that contains
information about the user's interaction
with your website or app such as paid
views form submissions product details
and more
and by utilizing a data layer you can
simplify the implementation of various
tracking and marking marketing tools
making it easier to customize your
analytics and Advertising Solutions
it can also help you improve the
accuracy and consistency of your data
collection thereby it reduces errors and
it reduces duplications my next tip is
to use variables in Google tag manager
variables are used to define and capture
Dynamic values that are used by tags and
triggers these values can include
information like page URL field values
click element attributes and so on by
using variables you can create more
flexible and Powerful tags and triggers
enabling you to better track and analyze
user behavior on your website or on your
app
variables can also simplify the
implementation of various marketing and
analytics solutions by allowing you to
reuse the same data across multiple tags
and triggers this can help you save time
reduce errors and making it easier to
maintain and update your tracking setup
then there is the use of folders folders
in Google tag manager are used to
organize and group tags triggers and
variables and they organize them in
logical categories
help you better manage and navigate
large and complex tracking setups by
providing a clear and structured view of
your implementation
so by using folders you can easily find
and update specific components of your
tracking setup improving the efficiency
of your workflow and they can also help
collaborate with other teams by
providing a shared view of your tracking
implementation
this can make sure that everybody is on
the same page and follows the same
naming convention and best practices
thereby you reduce the risk of errors
and the risk of confusion so the seventh
tip is to use templates templates in
Google tag manager provide pre-built
configurations for commonly used tags
and variables making it easier to set up
and use various marketing analytics
Solutions you've seen them in the demo
they can be created by Google they're
third-party vendors or by yourself and
they can be shared across accounts and
across containers
by using templates you reduce the time
and effort needed to implement complex
tracking Solutions there bomb then you
can then focus on analyzing the data and
improving your marketing strategy they
can also help you ensure that tags and
variables are implemented correctly and
consistently
thereby reducing your error and
improving the accuracy and the
reliability of your data collection so
there's a few more tips and tricks to go
the next one make sure that you review
and audit your Google tag manager setup
it's very important that you check
regularly that your tracking tags are
firing correctly and provide accurate
relevant data for your analysis by
refueling your tracking tags your
triggers your data layer you can
identify any errors or issues
you should also check for duplicate or
unnecessary tags and ensure that your
website's performance is not being
impacted by the tax
you should also review the user
permissions and access to Google tag
manager to make sure that only
authorized users can edit or view your
tags
by regularly refueling your version
history you can identify any changes or
updates made that may have affected your
tags or triggers
yes I will review and audit is essential
to ensure that your tracking data is
accurate and reliable now another one
which is very important in relation to
the
um the regular sort of audit is to make
sure that you use Version Control in
Google tag manager that's a very
powerful feature that allows you to keep
track of changes made in the containers
and easily roll back to previous
versions if necessary
so you can create a new version of the
container each time A Change Is Made
which which then can be viewed and
compared to previous versions
it helps you to collaborate more
effectively so each team member can see
what changes have been made and when
they have been made it also provides a
level of accountability and helps
prevent accidental changes that could
negatively impact your data collection
it's a very important best practice for
managing and maintaining accurate and
reliable data coming from your Google
tag manager and then finally make sure
that you stay up to date on Google tag
manager the Google tools they change
regularly they change often yeah so you
need to make sure that you know what the
latest features can offer you so follow
the official Google tag manager blog and
the Google analytics blog you can also
join the Google tag manager Community
forums there's lots of webinars about it
you can subscribe to newsletters from
digital marketing blogs and websites
that cover Google tag manager and then
of course you can follow industry
experts on social media platforms like
Twitter and Linkedin it's important to
regularly check for updates to ensure
that you are aware of new features
changes or best practices and then
there's of course also Google techno
it's just courses that you can attend
and training sessions to deepen your
understanding and knowledge of Google
tag manager
I think is the right choice for you to
upskill and learn all the Google
analytics techniques so hurry up and
find the course Link in the description
box for more details
let's go with the scenario that you have
a friend named Sam and he has a website
where he sells shoes but Sam doesn't
understand
why his website's not ranking number one
on Google and so typically ranked number
one on Google there are some factors
involved and those are factors that are
going to help Sam get his website ranked
number one on Google so he can sell his
shoes get traffic and convert that
traffic to conversions so there are
factors involved and so what are those
factors well it always starts with
keyword research so in order to rank for
a website where you sell shoes or you
sell products other products like
clothing or food or your automobile
website you know you're a mechanic it
doesn't matter whether you're selling to
customers or selling to other businesses
you have to start with the keyword
research and so we're going to go go
into really explicit detail on how to
conduct a proper keyword research and
then the second factor involved is high
quality content so in order to rank high
on Google search you need to have high
quality content so we're going to go
over what's involved with creating high
quality content then we're going to take
that content we're going to optimize it
using on page elements and website level
factors so we're going to take into
account what's involved with your
website and what's involved with
specific pages on your website in order
to rank number one on Google then we're
going to get into the off-site
engagement so when it comes to ranking
on Google you need to optimize your
website and you need to do some elements
off your website you need to be engaging
off your website meaning on other
websites and so we're going to talk
about what's involved with off-site
engagement so SEO being a major channel
for most companies and websites where
the opportunity to drive a lot of
traffic is there but you have to earn
that reward the reward is a lot of
traffic but you have to earn the reward
there's a lot of work involved and so
ideally what we want to do is follow
what we call the 80 20 rule when it
comes to search engine optimization and
ranking on Google and what do we mean by
the 80 20 rule well 80 20 means we're
investing 20 percent of our effort and
80 percent of the results are obtained
so we want to invest 20 and get back 80.
that's basically what we mean by 80 20.
so for example if 20 of our targeted
keywords bring in 80 of the traffic then
that's following the 80 20 rule or 20
percent of our landing pages Drive 80
percent of the overall traffic that's
fall in the 80 20 rule or 20 of our
backlinks pass 80 percent of our link
juice that's the 80 20 rule meaning
these targeted keywords these targeted
landing pages these trying to Target
backlinks using off-site engagement we
want to put in 20 of our effort on those
keywords landing pages and backlinks in
return for 80 percent of the results so
without further Ado let's get started
with the keyword research let's talk
about that keyword research for a
website with shoes and it doesn't really
matter what particular product you have
if you need to rank number one on Google
it all starts with the keywords as I
mentioned before and so in this example
if you have a website where you sell
shoes for kids you're going to want to
be found for certain keywords so the
obvious keyword here would be shoes for
kids well every keyword that you target
has search volume associated with it so
that means when we talk about search
volume we're talking about how many
people on average type in that keyword
or related keyword on google.com or
Google search and there's always an
average number of searches associated
with every keyword and we call that
search volume how much search volume so
obviously if we're going to Target a
keyword we want to have as much volume
as possible however there's always going
to be competition for those keywords
meaning there's always going to be other
websites who want to rank number one on
Google for the same keywords and we call
that competition or difficulty so for
every keyword you're going to have
volume and you're going to have
competition or difficulty and the
difficulty ranges as well depending on
the tool you use and we'll get into that
in a minute but search volume is how
much on average people are typing in
that keyword or close variance of that
keyword and the difficulty is measured
in terms of how many other websites are
trying to to rank for the same keyword
and so ideally when it comes to keyword
research we want to find that nice
balance we want high volume and we want
low competition but at the same time we
want to focus on keywords that are
highly relevant to our business so if
we're selling shoes for kids and shoes
for kids is highly relevant has high
volume and low competition then that's a
keyword we want to Target so we always
want to focus in on those three areas so
there's always a trade-off with keywords
so shoes for kids might have high volume
but also might have high competition or
difficulty if we look for another
keyword that's just as relevant for
example shoes for children it may still
have high search volume but the
competition or the difficulty may be
lower and if that's the case then that
may be a better keyword for us to Target
instead of something highly competitive
like shoes for kids we can focus on
another relevant keyword like shoes for
children with just as much volume and
lower competition and the reason why we
want lower competition is because we
want to be able to rank for that keyword
so the higher the competition the harder
it is for us to rank number one on
Google for that keyword and so the whole
idea Beyond keyword research is
analyzing and choosing the best keywords
so we want to identify a list of
keywords that are always relevant we
want to choose the keyword that your
competitors are ranking for and we want
to use third-party tools to choose
keywords to identify which keywords have
low competition and what keywords have
high search volume so one thing to take
into consideration when you're doing
keyword research is that the longer the
key word phrase or in other words long
tail keywords or keywords with three
keywords in the phrase or more you're
going to always have less competition
but there's always a trade-off with long
tail keywords meaning the longer the
keyword phrase there's going to be less
volume but the trade-off is less
competition and so what we want to do is
we want to brainstorm some ideas and
find those relevant keywords so let's
look at an example here so if we go to
Google ads so Google ads has a total
Keyword Planner and let's just say I
have a a website where I'm selling dried
figs and if I'm selling dried figs I
want people to buy these dried figs
however in order to attract them I want
to be able to show them that hey we have
a bunch of recipes and if I show you a
bunch of recipes where you can use dried
figs maybe you'll buy these dried figs
to use in these recipes and so we're
going to look for keywords related to
bread recipes because if we can optimize
for our recipes page for bread then that
will attract an audience who wants to
make bread and use dried figs with those
bread recipes so that's the example I'm
going to give here and so if I look at
the Keyword Planner and Google ads if I
just type in bread recipes what Google
is going to do is they're going to give
me an average monthly search volume so I
can see the average monthly search
volume here is 60 500. and so in order
to keyword research what I would
recommend is keep a spreadsheet and so
the idea behind the spreadsheet is to
document the volume and the competition
you're getting for certain keywords so
if I go into a spreadsheet here my theme
of keywords is bread recipes my keyword
is bread recipes and my volume therefore
is going to be sixty thousand five
hundred however if I go back into
Google's Keyword Planner Google is
telling me the competition is low so
that's great I want high volume I want
low competition but how low is low so we
want to be careful so so if we're going
to put in numbers into a spreadsheet we
want to figure out what that competition
really is for the keyword bread recipes
so if I go to Google and just type in
bread recipes I'm going to be able to
see
771 billion results for the keyword
bread recipes now is 771 billion are
real competition maybe maybe not what we
want to do is put in a syntax and we
want to put in the syntax all in title
and then colon space and then our
keyword and the reason why we do that in
search is because we want to be able to
identify the true competitive number or
the true number of websites who are
trying to rank for bread recipes and if
we put in the syntax all entitled colon
and then our keyword bread recipes we'll
be able to see that there are 998
000 results that's a lot lower than 771
billion so that means means that 998
000 sites or listings have the keyword
bread recipes in the title tag and the
title tag is what shows up in the search
engine results and so if I look down and
scroll down here I can see bread recipes
on every one of these title tags so
title tag is an important element to
rank number one on Google and we'll talk
about that in a few minutes but if we
understand that they're 998 000 results
with bread recipes in the title tag then
this tells us that those are the
websites who are trying to rank number
one on Google for that keyword and
therefore those are the websites we need
to jump over in order for our website to
rank number one on Google and so
therefore I'm going to put in 998
000 in my spreadsheet as the competitive
number and so now I could see for the
keyword bread recipes I have sixty
thousand five hundred and and if my
competition is 998 000 then my Kei or
keyword Effectiveness index or in other
words the ratio of volume to competition
is six percent so that's nothing more
than volume divided by competition so
that tells me that my Kei or my ratio
between volume competition is six
percent so remember we want more volume
than we want competition so anytime you
do a keyword research you're going to
find a number of different relevant
keywords so if I go back into Google's
Keyword Planner if I typed in bread
recipes you could see that Google is
going to give me a number of different
keywords related to bread recipes let's
just say I have another keyword that I
want to think about optimizing for being
ranked on Google for and that's banana
bread recipe very similar keyword has
bread recipes except it's a little
longer tail now if I type in banana
bread recipe and Google's Keyword
Planner now I can see the average
monthly search volume has actually gone
up it's 368
000. I can also see the competition is
low so those are good signs so now I can
see 368
000 I'm going to go ahead and put that
in my spreadsheet now I'm gonna go into
Google I'm gonna put in my syntax all in
title I'm going to put in banana bread
recipe I'm going to hit enter and now I
can see I have 233
000 results with the keyword banana
bread recipe in the title tag so if I
look at the title tags I can see banana
bread recipe banana bread recipe banana
bread recipe on all the listings in the
Google search results so that tells me I
have 233
000 results that I have to jump over in
order to rank number one on Google so
I'm gonna put 233
000 in my spreadsheet now I can see my
Kei or my volume to competition ratio is
157 158 and so to me that's a lot better
number to work with or in other words
that's a lot better keyword because it's
just as relevant and it has a higher
ratio of volume to competition so
therefore banana bread recipe is going
to be a better keyword to optimize for
in order to rank number one on Google so
that's the whole idea behind keyword
research you want to brainstorm ideas
there are plenty of tools out there so
the tool I recommend is Google ads
Keyword Planner Google is going to give
you how much search volume they're going
to tell you the competition but then
you're going to go into Google search
you're going to use the syntax all in
title to get a more accurate read on the
actual competitive number and so to find
out how keywords that you're competitor
editors are ranking for you can use
those keyword tools that I mentioned
another tool that I use is mass so Moz
if you go to moz.com they have a tool
called keyword Explorer so if we just
type in the keyword for example bread
recipes it's going to be able to tell us
how much volume and the difficulty so
you can use other tools at your disposal
figure out the volume and the difficulty
there are plenty of tools out there but
the one thing I would just make sure is
you use everything at your disposal so
you can use social media to find the
most shared article for a particular
topic or keyword like bread recipes you
could check other platforms that have a
lot of shared content like Reddit and
quora where you can ask people about
certain topics using keywords to figure
out how much competition or volume there
might be you can stay up to date on
industry news to get an idea of what
types of game words are trending but
when it comes to key words and keyword
research remember for every web page we
want to be able to pick two keywords we
want a primary and secondary keyword so
when we do keyword research and we enter
all our keywords into our spreadsheet we
want to be able to have a number of
different keywords in this case we're
focusing on the theme bread recipes we
want to have different keywords because
we want to be able to choose a primary
keyword and a secondary keyword because
we want to be able to focus on multiple
keywords for each page because we don't
want to put necessarily all our eggs in
one basket meaning we won't want to put
all our emphasis just on one keyword to
rank for we want multiple keywords to
try and rank for so the primary keyword
can Define the nature of our business
the secondary keyword could be just
highly relevant to our keyword at the
end of the day we want to choose
multiple keywords words to try and rank
on Google for that page so for example
we have a Blog and we're using ice cream
recipes and we're blogging about ice
cream recipes we can have the primary
keyword that is about ice cream recipes
or homemade ice cream recipes we're
going to always want to find out what
the volume and the competition is our
secondary keyword could be built around
other similar keywords like low-fat ice
cream recipes or fat free ice cream
recipes or low-fat homemade ice cream
recipes those are complementary keywords
just like our bread recipes and banana
bread recipe so one thing we want to do
when we do keyword research is we want
to be able to Target one keyword per
content when you can Target many we want
to be able to Target multiple keywords
not necessarily Target one keyword and
so we want to be able to Cluster
keywords so we don't want to Target just
one and we want to Target multiple
keywords per page and when we talk about
clustering if we go back to our keyword
research what we're doing is we're
clustering a bunch of keywords under the
theme bread recipes and so by looking at
the volume looking at the competition
looking at the Kei we can choose
different keywords for our page and
that's what we mean by clustering we
want to Cluster keywords into a Content
frame so why Target only one keyword per
content when we can Target many because
we don't want to put all our eggs in one
basket we don't want to Target just one
keyword we want to Target many and so
that means clustering your keywords into
a theme and choosing multiple keywords
for that particular page and when we do
that we have a better opportunity to
rank high on Google Search and the whole
idea behind ranking high on Google
Search is we can get the volume so if we
know we're ranked number one on Google
search for bread recipes or banana bread
recipe we know we stand a chance of
getting a majority of the volume
associated with that keyword and if we
can get the volume and get the traffic
then we can get the conversions so let's
move on to high quality content and talk
about the impact content has on your
ability to get your website ranked
number one on Google so let's just say
you have content on your website and the
content is ranking on you know page four
of Google and it's that blog with ice
cream recipes and if it's just content
for the sake of content is not really
informative then it's not necessarily
going to get good engagement in the eyes
of Google you know they want to rank
content that's very informative it's
very fresh it's exciting to read it's
interesting it's going to have good
engagement so if it's a recipe or an
article about any topic if it's the
content is just non-informative then
you're not going to get good engagement
and when you don't get good engagement
if people don't stay on the site to
engage in the content and they just
leave the website after landing on the
page causing a bounce then the content
is just going to continue to fall down
the rankings and we want to prevent that
we want to move up the rankings we want
to be number one on Google we don't
necessarily want to fall in the rankings
for our content so content is a key
driver in being able to rank number one
on Google so if the content is on page
nine what can we do well we want to be
able to you know take that content and
do something with it we feel like we did
write engaging content so let's go ahead
and share it on social media and to me
social media is a good platform to share
your content because on social media
platforms like Facebook for example you
you're building a community on that
platform that Community is already
interested in your content so if you're
sharing an ice cream recipe especially
in the summertime and you're engaging
with your community on that platform
then the likelihood of that community on
that platform is going to increase
engagement increased engagement will
send social signals to the search engine
that says hey this content is good
quality likewise for any other platform
most social media platforms have
engagement metrics and those engagement
metrics pass signals is it good is it
not good do we like this content are we
giving it a thumbs up are we going to
want to follow it are we going to want
to share it and so if you share content
that you feel is engaging on social
platforms then it's going to be engaging
and it's likely going to cause an
increase in engagement for example a
decrease in balances and once you share
that call quality content then the
likelihood of it moving up the rankings
even as far as number one on Google is
going to be greater so you always want
to start out writing good quality
content so let's talk about good quality
content because Google does take content
seriously they do take into account what
other people think of that content so
high quality content is an important
factor so how to create good content
that's always the question so let's talk
about some best practices here remember
in the last segment we talked about
keyword research so we want to perform
good keyword research why because we
want to choose keywords remember we're
choosing multiple keywords per page one
keyword could be related to our brand
one keyword could be related to the
content but another keyword could be
related to a user's intent like recipes
if you recall the example we use with
bread recipes maybe somebody's looking
to type in a keyword that says how do I
make you know a bread or how do I make a
specific type of bread or how do I make
banana bread or what's the best recipe
for banana bread they're question
related and we want to be able to answer
those questions so that's where choosing
those right keywords that's going to
respond to a user's intent so starts
with choosing the right keywords so
remember we talked about a number of
different tools when we talk about
keyword research so there's a research
tool that you can use called phrase.io
and that will help you do quick research
on you know keywords and Trends and
whatnot so if you know about a research
tool that you use for keyword research
then drop us a comment below I'd be
interested in getting your comments
about keyword research and what research
tools are out there so if you know
something better than phrase.io drop a
comment below and we'd be interested in
getting your perspective so keyword
research is key but create creating
content that fulfills users requirements
so answering those questions it's a
recipe we want to answer that question
if it's directions we want to answer
that question if they don't know how to
do something we want to answer that
question then that's the whole idea
behind content content is not just to
fill a page it's to really fulfill users
requirements that's when you get good
engagement so if somebody's typing in
something on Google and they're looking
for an answer your content should answer
that question but we also want to make
the content readable so in other words
you know write for your audience don't
impress anybody with very high
vocabulary type words that somebody
doesn't necessarily know the meaning of
don't use jargon don't use a street
language for example use everyday common
language that's just easily digestible
when your audience is reading and then
we want to keep that content organized
and so when we mean organized we want to
use headers and sub headers you know
break your content into paragraphs keep
the flow organized if we can keep the
flow organized then it's going to be
easier for somebody to read and then
it's okay to add resources especially
resources from credible sites so if you
can incorporate those resources in there
then it's just going to add The
credibility to your content let the
audience know that hey I've done my
research on this topic and this is what
this person has to say about it this
person who seems to be credible okay so
it only adds value to your content so
these are all tips to Remember When
creating content and then the one
important tip here is we want to use
white hat techniques and when we say
white hat techniques that means you know
if we've chosen keywords that are going
to answer somebody's question we don't
want to stuff those keywords into the
content we want the content to be
naturally written so when we say opt for
white hacked techniques that's what we
mean write the content naturally keep it
organized keep it readable include
third-party sources and make sure it
answers a question so there are
different types of content so there's
content where you just write words to
install text based you could also use an
infographic infographic is simply just a
graphic that visualizes exactly what
you're trying to explain for example if
we want to write an article about how to
write good engaging content we don't
necessarily have to write all that out
as a text we can create an infographic
so for example here's an infographic on
20 effective ways to basically not bore
your readers but write engaging content
so you could see this is an infographic
it's all graphically laid out so
infographics tend to be easier to
understand because they're visual
they're easy for the end user to
comprehend because there's generally no
jargon it's usually images that are
portraying the point of what you're
trying to get across and so it tends to
break it up the monotony of just text
it's more visually appealing and it's
laid out and organized so you can see
this infographic has 20 different steps
or rules and they lay those out all here
in this infographic and the great thing
I like about infographics is you could
you could share them on social media you
can re-engage them as a post you can
save them from really any social
platform so infographics tend to tell a
better story and versus say just writing
text you can use video and images so you
don't necessarily have to lay it all out
in an infographic you can certainly
insert a video or an image into your
content especially if it's a blog post
if it's a blog post then sometimes video
and images on its own tell the story you
don't necessarily need text to go ahead
and tell your story a video or an image
as they say tells a thousand words and
so images and videos are great to use in
a blog post so using different forms of
content you know you always want to
review your content when a user dwells
on your web page for a longer time
Google will tend to think okay this
person's engaged so we're going to rank
that favorable so if you're using
infographics videos and images then the
chances of somebody being more engaged
are going to increase versus just text
that's not well organized and written
out in a way that somebody doesn't
necessarily understand so be creative in
the types of content you use so longer
engaging content tends to bode well with
search engines so this is according to
HubSpot so the more word count you use
the more words you use the chances of
you ranking higher are going to be
better just take into account not best
practices you want to maybe break up the
content with an image organize it make
it engaging use headers so it's not
necessarily just words it's the words
and how those words are written how
they're structured the types of keywords
you're using how you're engaging with
your audience there's a lot of factors
again there's best practices we just
went over but the key is you know if you
have longer more engaging content then
it's going to bode better for you on
search engines so a couple of steps to
create high quality content so you want
to begin with a comprehensive
introduction so always introduce your
content remember the content should be
relevant to the keyword so if you're
choosing keywords and your keyword
research think about answering that
question if somebody's typing in bread
recipes maybe they're looking for banana
bread recipes how to make the best
banana bread or how to make banana bread
using dried figs we want to be able to
align our content with that keyword
naturally you want to create a title
that's worthy that's click worthy so
remember if you're in Google search and
you're doing search for something simple
like bread recipes we want to make
something that's going to be you know
engaging for somebody to click on like
easy perfect e-spread or easy crusty
French bread or something that's going
to be engaging you know the best bread
recipes or how to make the best homemade
bread you know something that's going to
draw somebody's attention to the title
of that blog post so we want to include
LSI keywords so what I mean by LSI
keywords in your content we mean you
know long tail keywords make it natural
headings and subheadings should consist
of keywords and variants so if you're
writing headers and subheaders include
the keyword in there and that way the
content always stays relevant to the
audience okay shorten your sentences and
paragraphs so don't write long
paragraphs remember we want to break
this up we want to make it easy for the
end user to read and we want to always
put internal links on our blog post why
because if we have internal links then
if we have a link from one blog post to
another blog post or say our blog post
to an internal page on our website we
want to make sure that it's relevant
content that way somebody's reading
something and you have an internal link
let's just say from a bread recipes page
to a banana bread recipes page then they
may find it interesting click on that
link and go to the banana bread recipes
page so it's keeping somebody engaged on
your website so putting in internal
linking will help keep the end user
engaged because you're offering up links
that's relevant to the content you
always want to break up that content
with images okay we want to use alt tags
meaning we want to pan the image with
text so that way if the image doesn't
load then at least the alt text will
load so we can incorporate call out
boxes and more importantly we want to
update our content regularly so we
always want to get the best recipe out
there if it's banana bread or different
ways to Crepe banana bread or always
just coming up with ways to update the
content so we want to keep our content
our blog post fresh and then we want to
include a CTA call to action if we
include a call to action then that's
going to keep somebody engaged and have
them act on your content so these are
steps to creating high quality content
and so let's look at an example here and
this is a three-month-old post on
BuzzFeed and it's 21 pictures that
restore your faith in humanity so it has
a lot of likes a lot of tweaks and that
means it's engaged people are engaged
when reading that and so if we go and
look at it as an example we could see it
on a buzzfeed here 21 pictures that will
restore your faith in humanity so this
was written back in 2012. again a lot of
Engagement but if we look at it we can
see immediately that it's taking into
account third-party sources it's got
some content it's got images it's being
broken up by images we could see there's
call to actions on there in the form of
social so people can go ahead and go
ahead and share it if they like it okay
it includes videos includes images
third-party sources so it's a good post
because listen you know it's engaging
content it's probably answering
somebody's question about humanity and
we could see clearly that look you know
there's a lot of different examples here
from a lot of different sources and we
could take action on this content so not
just video not just images but text is
well and so it's very engaging answers
questions takes into account the
different types of content available so
this is a good post in that regard so
content's updated regularly it's
engaging and it includes sources from
high Authority websites some do's and
don'ts on the content so take into
account the best practices I mentioned
about creating high quality content okay
answer those questions that the end user
wants to hear you know because that
likely is going to be their search and
so you want to be able to respond to the
end user that's part of creating high
quality content different types of
content I.E in the form of infographics
or videos or text or images you can add
images from public domain sites you can
be relatable and use examples to clarify
points just like the BuzzFeed article
simplify complex words don't use
sophisticated language talk to your
audience as if you they were standing
right in front of you and use bullet
points to exemplify your examples your
points so some Do's the don'ts obviously
don't lift content we don't want to lift
content from another website so that's
plagiarism so we want to have our own
unique content we also don't want to
take images from other websites and so
if you do happen to find an image that
works for your post and it's on somebody
else's website ideally that's not a good
situation but if you do happen to do
that then always give credit to the
website okay so if you took it from
xyz.com credit xyz.com for the image and
even put a link back but ideally you
don't want to take images from other
websites just as much as you don't want
to take copy you don't want to take
images use your own imagery and content
but if you don't have imagery then you
can always go to stock photography there
are plenty of websites out there there
where you can sign up for a subscription
like Adobe stock images as an example
you can sign up for an account and in
some cases you can sign up for a free
account and use stock imagery okay don't
give less information to your audience
give them to your audience what they
deserve which is the information they're
looking for they're looking for the best
banana bread recipes give them the best
banana bread recipes incorporate your
own images break it up with titles give
them a good quality piece of content
that they're going to be able to engage
with and so if you put long paragraphs
in your content then it's going to be
less engaging so try to avoid those long
paragraphs remember shorten up the
paragraphs keep the language simple add
in images answer those questions use
third-party credible sources but write
it in your own words and you should be
on your way to creating good quality
content okay so now that we've talked
about high quality content in order to
get your pages ranked high on Google
search let's turn our attention to
optimizing on-page elements and discuss
some website level factors that are both
going to help you rank high on Google
search so let's just do an overview of
what we're talking about when we talk
about on-page elements and website level
factors so optimizing on page elements
include a number of different things but
primarily we're going to focus in on
meta tags also known as meta description
tags header tags also known as title
tags and URLs so those are just some of
the on-page elements we want to be able
to optimize using relevant keywords in
order to rank on Google search we also
want to take a look at some website
factors that will affect our ranking on
Google search they include website
architecture having a secure website
having a site map and taking a look at
page speed so all of those are some of
the website factors we need to take into
account in order to rank high on Google
search so title tag and meta description
together are considered meta tags so
both play an important role in ranking
high on Google so we want to be able to
write unique title and descriptions for
each page on our website when I say
unique that means a title In The Meta
description need to be different for
every page on the website and so if
you're not quite sure what a title tag
in a meta description tag is if you go
to search and just type in any
particular search query the title tag is
what's going to show up here in bold and
then the description is going to show up
below it below the URL and that's going
to describe the page so both of these
meta tags are important because it
describes rise what your page is all
about and that's what Google uses in the
search results pages so we want to be
able to pay attention to the length of
our meta tags so if we go back to our
search results Pages met title tags are
generally 60 65 characters meta
description tags are generally 160
characters so anything really longer
than that then what's going to happen is
the meta description tag or the title
tag will get truncated and so if we look
here for example we could see all of the
title tags here fit the 65 character
limit but if you run over the character
count on meta description then Google is
going to truncate the copy so you want
to stay within your parameters in order
to avoid getting your content trunk at
it and so the other thing when we're
writing title meta description tags we
want to minimize keyword repetition so
if we're optimal advising for keyword we
don't want to necessarily just plug that
keyword into the title tag and meta
description multiple times we want to
make sure our title tags and meta
descriptions are naturally written so if
somebody's typing for banana bread
recipe with dried figs you know we want
to have a nice title tag and a
description that is going to get
somebody to respond based on their need
and so we definitely want to avoid
keyword repetition but we want to be
able to use that keyword in the title
tag because if you remember from the
earlier segment when we did the all in
title syntax to find out exactly how
many competitors were using that
particular keyword well we obviously
want to use that keyword in the title
tag because again the title tag is an
important factor when it comes to search
engine results so we want to use the
keyword but we want to avoid stuffing or
using it repetitively in our title tag
and our meta description we want the a
title tag and The Meta description to
describe the page sound natural but also
be engaging because the point is we want
people to click on our link and go to
our website from search engines so title
tags with numbers tend to result in
higher click-through rates this is
according to mods so for example if you
just put in a title tag that says learn
digital marketing well that may work but
if you put a number in there like five
easy ways to learn digital marketing
that might get somebody to click on your
link and go to your website so having
questions in your meta tags can also
increase your click-through rate for
example if you just put learn the
importance of first page rankings not
too bad but again generic but if you put
it into the formal question how to rank
number one on Google it's more action
oriented it's gonna get somebody to
resonate with the question that they
have and that may be their query how to
rank number one one on Google and so
these techniques will help you get
higher click-through rates and so
according to backlinko title tag with a
keyword can improve site ranking so
remember we want to include that keyword
in the title tag even though we only
have 65 characters we want to include
that keyword but we want to avoid
stuffing the keyword in there we want to
again make the title tag action oriented
maybe with a number maybe as a question
with the keyword in there once naturally
not easy to do but that's the beauty of
SEO if you can follow these best
practices and write a good title tag
then the chances of you improving in
your search results are going to be
greater so having only one H1 tag in
your post is going to be good so
remember when somebody clicks on a link
so let's say they do find a title tag
engaging and they click on this this
link here and they go to that website
you know you want to start out with
having that particular H1 tag because
the H1 tag especially with the keyword
in it is going to signal to Google hey
we're organizing our page and because
it's an H1 tag it's important we're
structuring the page according to best
practices so having only one H1 tag in
your post is definitely helpful having
multiple tags H tags in your post help
organize the page a lot better so we
want to add that targeted keyword in
that tag and your tatter tag should be
relevant to the content so if we go back
to our example of the using dried figs
with banana breads well the title says
California fake banana bread and
remember the last segment when we're
talking about high quality content well
look no further than including a video
into our content so not only will this
video help keep the engagement high but
it breaks up the monotony of the page
and it's from a third party source so it
adds credibility to the page so adding a
video based on the last segment of high
quality content definitely helps with
ranking high on Google search so
following hierarchical structure that
means putting those H tags in there H2
tags help break up the content and we
want to avoid repetition of H1 tags on
your different web pages of your site
meaning don't just put the same H1 tag
with the same keyword in it and keeping
it blase we want to make those H1 tags
exciting to read but also used
appropriately to break up the content so
remember all white hat techniques we
want to avoid hidden tags we want to
avoid stuffing keywords we want things
to be natural we don't want things to be
forced and your H1 tag should be 20 to
70 characters don't make long h110 so if
we go back to our page example a short
sweet tag here California fig banana
bread it's relevant to the content it's
short sweet it breaks up the monotony of
the content and more importantly and
again any content you have on the page
should always answer the user's intent
remember people are using search to
answer questions find information our
content should be able to answer that
for them so according to John Moeller
senior webmaster Trends Analyst at
Google header tags would definitely help
Google for rankings in the search
results so we want to use header tags so
when it comes to URLs we want to use
hyphens and avoid underscores so if we
look at this URL here this uses hyphens
fig and banana bread so it's all broken
up with hyphens that's a best practice
remember canonical URLs a canonical URL
signals to Google this is the original
content so we want to use original
content and if you have multiple sources
of content out there on say different
websites we want to use a canonical tag
to signal to Google this is the original
content please Index this content and
that doesn't hurt to use a favicon URL
meaning a small icon it helps to break
up the monotony and help your URL stand
out we can add targeted keywords in the
URL so again looking at the URL here I
can see we're using targeted keyword as
part of the URL structure Fagan banana
bread and that is the H1 tag is fake
banana bread so it's all consistent and
it flows naturally URLs that are no
longer existing then we want to be able
to set up a redirect for those URLs
meaning a 301 redirect is a server
response for Google that says Hey Google
this page is no longer available but it
we permanently redirected it to this
page page which is now available so
that's what a 301 redirect does it helps
signal to Google and all the other
search engines that if the page is no
longer there that's fine you're just
going to go to this page this is the
page that's permanently there now and
another thing we want to do here is if
you have mobile URLs you want to include
those in the site map and we're going to
hit on that in just a minute but all
urls should be mobile friendly as well
as desktop friendly meaning take into
account this best practices keep your
URLs short use hyphens put the keyword
in that URL and make it easy to
understand want to avoid capital letters
in the URLs the URLs are case sensitive
so go lower case you should always go
lowercase from the URL readable URLs
again the rule of thumb here is if you
understand what the URL is then Google
is going to understand what the URL is
so the shorter the URL the easier it is
to read it the easier it is to read the
better chance you have to rank high on
Google search so according to backlink
to URLs that are shorter definitely
definitely help you rank so we want to
be able to shorten those URLs keep them
short and sweet don't make them long and
unreadable so those are some on
optimized ways or on-page elements that
help you optimize now we want to look at
some website level factors that will
help you optimize and rank high on
Google search so good site structure
provides better crawling for search
engine Bots and what do we mean by that
well we mean having your site organized
in a fashion that Google's going to be
able to find all the pages so what do we
mean by that create a logical hierarchy
structure so if you're selling shoes you
know you're going to have a home page
break the structure up into men's shoes
women's shoes Children's Shoes then
under men's shoes you can have it by
brand it could be Nike Puma Adidas on
the women's side it could be Nike Puma
Adidas on the child side it could be
Nike Puma Adidas and so you want to keep
the structure flow and a hierarchy so we
want to balance the amount of
subcategories within each category so
the men's if it has Nike Puma Adidas the
women should have Nike Puma Adidas and
so you want to code your site navigation
and CSS or HTML meaning we want to be
able to use something that Google's
going to be able to index so most sites
are built in HTML and that's what Google
likes to index they like to index
something that they could take back to
their servers and then more importantly
build a comprehensive structure for
internal linking so internal links mean
that if you're on a site you should have
natural links pointing to other pages on
your website so to keep the flow going
we don't want to have unnatural inbound
links you always want to have natural
internal links to keep the flow of the
user going from one page to the other so
here I can see as an example all the
ingredients in this recipe well this has
an internal link to another page on our
site and this happens to link to a page
where somebody can buy the ingredients
so it's a natural internal link so John
Doherty of Credo has claimed that one of
the biggest changes that he can make in
fixing the creative website is
architecture so for example in Credo
John Doherty has increased the organic
sessions by 74 in Pages by per session
by 41 just by changing the site
architecture so you'd be surprised by
changing the site architecture what that
will do to engagement and so let's turn
our attention to secure versus
non-secure so what we mean by that is
securing your site we want to make it
sure that compliant with certain
protocols and so if we go back here we
could see that this particular site is
compliant it is secure https means it
has as a secure license meaning the site
is secure so Google likes secure versus
non-secure so non-secure would be HTTP
so we want https as our protocol and
what that means is just enabling SSL
certificates and that means when you
enable an SSL certificate that means
your domain or your protocol is going to
be turned to https so Google prefers
sites that are secure versus non-secure
so if you use hsts as a protocol that
adds an extra layer of security over the
https and
hsts prevents cookie hijacking so adding
multiple layers of security always helps
in my opinion if you have an HTTP
website a non-secure website you should
look into buying an SSL certificate
getting your sites flipped over to https
because what's is going to happen is
your your rail structure is going to
change when your url structure changes
Google is going to recognize that
because they're going to index your site
and when they index your site they're
going to see those secure URLs and
that's going to work favorably in your
favor and help you rank higher on Google
search so websites using secure or https
have a higher chance of ranking higher
so https is a ranking signal because
Google indexes those pages so let's also
talk about site Maps so sitemap is one
of the most important ways to improve
your website ranking why well because
sitemaps are a way to organize all your
URLs into one file so we're basically
going to prioritize all our web pages in
a site map so if you go to any
particular website and you type in
sitemap.xml you're likely going to see
all the pages on your website so usually
the site map is located in the root
directory so if I type in sitemap.xml
I'm going to be able to see all the
pages in my root directory and I can
also prioritize them I can also alert
Google as to how often they change and
every page is going to have a date stamp
associated with it so Google can
actually see how often it changes so
remember we want our content to be
updated frequently so content's not
updated frequently or it's not fresh
then Google's going to see that size
that date stamp that last modification
down so we want to be able to make sure
contents updated frequently we want to
let Google know that we change it
frequently and we want to be able to
prioritize our Pages let Google know hey
these pages are important to us so all
that can be set up in a sitemap we want
to be able to add canonical versions of
URLs in the site map so we want to be
able to add all our original URLs in our
sitemap and so we always want to build
Dynamic urls sitemap apps for larger
websites and what I mean by Dynamic URLs
that means that if I look at this side
map and we're always adding content
let's just say in the form of a Blog
well guess what we want those pages to
be added to the sitemap as they're
published so as we add pages to the blog
or to the site then they should
automatically be added to the sitemap
and so in effect what's going to happen
is we're going to be able to see the
site map grow with more URLs when the
sitemap grows with more URLs then that
means then Google's going to index more
pages they're going to index more fresh
pages so they're going to be able to get
those pages that are just published
quicker so that's the whole idea behind
Dynamic sitemaps is we want to be able
to capture all the URLs just as they're
published and we want to be able to
maintain our sitemaps and so I would
always recommend a dynamic sitemap but
you can always create your own sitemap
just by going to a total call XML
sitemap so if I just type in XML
sitemaps into Google search here I can
see XML sitemaps generator and I can be
able if I have a small website just
create a free and simple site map on my
own when XML sitemaps creates it or your
platform creates a dynamic sitemap
either way the sitemaps going to sit in
the root directory and then what we want
to do in turn is let Google know where
that sitemap is so in search console we
want to be able to submit the sitemap so
you're going to add the site map you're
going to let Google know where it is it
should be in the root directory and it
should be called sitemap.xml and when
you do that Google's going to be able to
take those URLs and index them so we
could see we submitted 528 URLs Google
index 521 so one thing about URLs here
is when we create a site map we're
putting all your URLs in there we do not
add no index URLs in your site map when
what that means is that any URL we don't
want Google to index we're just going to
exclude from the sitemap okay so we want
Google to take all the URLs we want
indexed and put them in the sitemap so
according to edgy using sitemaps for SEO
can increase your website's visibility
and help you get indexed why because
what you're in effect doing is taking
all your URLs that you want index you're
telling Google how often they're
modified you're telling Google which
ones are important and you're submitting
that to Google and so Google's going to
be able to take all these URLs quicker
index them quicker and when they're
indexed quicker you can get rent quicker
and when you get ranked quicker you can
get traffic quicker so that's the whole
idea behind sitemaps so let's turn our
attention to page speed now so when the
last factors for our website besides
architecture making it secure and adding
site Maps is we want to take a look at
how quick our Pages load here are some
tips in order to optimize page speed
because ideally the quicker a page loads
the more engaged the user is going to be
if it takes a longer time for the page
to load all the elements of that page
then what's going to happen is the user
is going to get impatient maybe leave
the website all together or go to
another page and so we want to be able
to optimize images so any image that's
of large size in terms of megabytes we
want to be able to optimize that
compress the image so that's one way to
speed up page speed we want to use a
simple website design you know HTML with
CSS or cascading style sheets just a
simple design with simple a hierarchy
and website navigation structure so
nothing fancy nothing complex just a
simple website design with optimized
images we want to leverage browser
caching and we want to upgrade the
server response time meaning all your
files are sitting on the server so when
somebody it goes to web page the server
is serving up all of those files the
images the text Etc and so we want the
server to respond as quick as possible
so when it comes to page speed we can
look at the factors affecting page speed
and Google analytics so if I go to
Google analytics and I go under behavior
and I go under site speed and I go to
overview I'm going to be able to see
what my average load time is for my site
and ideally we want our pages to load as
quick as possible so that means anything
under four seconds anything four seconds
or higher and it's likely the end user
is going to leave the page there's a
correlation BP between page load time
and bounce rate and so what Google
actually does is give you speed
suggestions so if we do have a page that
loads slow we can just go to speed
suggestions in Google analytics and we
go to speed suggestions then Google's
going to be able to tell us hey okay
this particular page load fast this
potato page loads slow and if it loaded
slow why is it loading slow so here we
could see the home page of the example
is loading on average of seven seconds
well if we look here they're going to
give us some suggestions so if I click
on this page speed suggestions it's
going to load a report and a tool called
page speed insights and basically what
it's then going to do after it's done
running is it's going to tell me all the
ways in which I can optimize my pages
not only for desktop but also for mobile
so here I can see for desktop or for
mobile I can look at some ways in which
I can optimize it to increase page speed
for example sizing my images properly
server response time reducing my server
response time avoiding multiple page
redirects so there's a lot of
opportunities that we can do to speed up
page load time and all that's found in
page speed insights and all that's found
within Google analytics so remember
optimizing code minimizing redirects
optimizing your images upgrading your
server response and all of those are
factors and so again you can go into
analytics page speed insights and you
can see exactly what Google is
recognizing as what's lowering or
slowing down your page load time so
Google takes site speed as one of the
most important ranking factors why
because they're going to rank Pages not
only with high quality content that are
relevant to the keyword queries but they
want those pages to have a good user
experience so somebody clicks on the
page then the user should be able to see
that content fairly quickly and so
that's why it's such an important factor
so the quicker your pages load the
chances of you ranking higher are going
to be better so according to web
performance today Walmart as an example
experience decline in conversions so
what they did was has looked at their
page speed and when they looked at their
page speed you'd be surprised what that
did just increasing it from one to four
seconds or decreasing it basically
increased conversion so there's always
going to be a correlation between how
quick a page loads and how engaged the
user is because if it's users engaged
they're going to stay on the site and if
they stay on the site then their chances
of converting are going to be higher so
just even one to two seconds increase
and Page low is low time will make a
world of difference in terms of
Engagement and conversions let's turn
our attention to off-site engagement so
previously we talked about on-page
elements and website factors that are
fact our rankings for search results but
we also need to turn our attention away
from our website meaning what we do on
our website and turn our attention what
we can do for our website off our
website and onto other websites so
that's offside engagement and so let's
look get an example so that ice cream
recipes blog so we did everything we
possibly could we updated The Meta tags
the title tag The Meta description we
added H1 tags we've made sure the site
architecture was sound we submitted a
site map we we made sure the page load
was good and fast so we did all the
things we're supposed to do on our web
page but we're still not ranking well
what do we need to do well we need to
turn our attention away from our website
into other websites we call this off
site or off-page SEO and we need to
basically generate links from high
quality sites back to our site so if
we've done everything we can on our own
website and we're still not ranking
where we want to be well then we need to
turn our attention to other websites and
so if we turn our attention other
websites and other websites that are
relevant other websites that are of
quality uh other websites that have high
domain Authority then we're going to see
an increase in rankings so it's just a
matter of getting quality links from
quality websites that are relevant
that's what's going to move the needle
on search after we've taken care of all
the on-page elements so more backlinks
from high domain Authority results in
higher rankings SEO is a combination
between what we do on our website
meaning optimizing the page and making
sure our website has good site
architecture and follows the best
practices in terms of site maps and Page
load then we need to turn our attention
to the backlinking to improve our domain
Authority so according to backlinko
analysis off-site engagement is one of
the most important elements for ranking
number one in Google so you can't just
focus your attention on updating the
title tag and making sure the pages load
fast you have have to turn your
attention as well to getting back
lengths from high quality sites that's
off-site engagement and so gaining links
back links from multiple domains is
vital it's vital because they bring
referring traffic to your site they
bring credibility to your site but more
importantly Google is going to recognize
the relationship between these sites and
your website and if these sites that
have backlinks or links pointing to your
site and if they're of high quality then
we call that passing link shoes so it's
going to bring quality to you in terms
of organic search so if we look at an
example if I do a search for banana
bread recipe they're 241 billion results
for banana bread recipe Why did this
particular page from Simply Recipes rank
number one well we can turn our
attention to Moz and Maz has a report
called link Explorer and so Moz link
Explorer report helps us identify our
own page Authority our own domain
Authority and how many links we have
from other quality websites so if I put
that particular URL into link Explorer
and notice the URL here is short even
though it uses an underscore when it
should use a hyphen it's still ranked
number one and why because off page
elements help this page rank number one
why their page Authority out of 100 is
58. their domain Authority out of 100 is
82 and what does that mean well that
means that they have a lot of good links
from other domains of high quality they
have 824 linking domains to this one
domain they have 3600 inbound links and
they're ranking for a lot of different
keywords so if we scroll down we're
going to be able to see kind of a
breakout the quality of websites that
are linking to them so they have 19
domains with a domain authority of 91 to
100 linking to them they have 15 domains
between the range of 81 and 90. so what
does that tell me between 15 and 19
that's 34 particular domains that are
very high quality linking to it and so
we could see the breakout of the linking
domains we could see the top file links
to the site and we can see the page
Authority so the link Explorer report
gives us an overview of what pages are
linking to ours and it also gives us an
idea of what our own page Authority and
domain Authority are because domain
Authority and Page Authority both need
to be high in order for us to rank on
Google search in order for it to get
high we need links from high quality
sites so that's the whole idea behind
off-site engagement so some of the
offsite engagement prints are influencer
marketing meaning is there somebody out
there on social who has a huge following
but not only do they have a huge phone
but are they relevant to our product for
example Usain Bolt who's a famous
Sprinter if we're selling shoes and
we're selling Nike shoes maybe Usain
Bolt can reference us on Twitter or
Facebook that's influencer marketing
getting people to influencing people to
buy our product we can engage with
audiences on multiple social media
platforms like Facebook and Twitter
meaning if we're running a promotion on
those running shoes then we can promote
that on Facebook okay we can promote
that on Twitter we can also bookmark our
webpage on popular bookmarking sites
like StumbleUpon we can also put our
content on discussion forums like Reddit
we can join High PR quality q a sites
excuse me and post answers to questions
related to business like quora.com so we
can engage in sharing our content and
answering questions so there's lots of
ways to get links to your website if you
have a blog post as an example you can
make sure that maybe that content is
shared on a similar blog post so if you
have an ice cream recipe blog post well
maybe you can look at a dessert blog
post and share your content on that
particular blog post and have a back
link pointing from that blog post to
yours as an example and you can
reciprocate so the whole idea of content
is sharing the content but at the same
time of sharing it you're producing
backlinks and backlinks help domain
Authority so not only did I help domain
Authority but they improve the search
rankings so in Google's eyes the higher
your domain Authority higher the page
Authority in Google's eyes that means
your page is important it's incredible
herbal and we're going to improve it in
the search engine rankings it increases
brand visibility if we have our content
on a highly engageable website a highly
popular website or blog it's not it's
going to lift our brand visibility if we
have Usain Bolt who's very famous
Sprinter do some influence in marketing
for us then that's going to increase our
brand visibility so anytime we can
associate with something that has some
influence or some clout or high domain
Authority then it's only going to
increase our brand awareness and
visibility so again it's going to
increase our domain Authority because of
the association of passing link juice
from one domain to another it's going to
then as a result increase referral
traffic because if we're on a high
quality website that gets a lot of
traffic then the chances of some of that
traffic going our site is going to be
great and again it improves The
credibility and Trust of our website and
that's what we want we want Google to
trust us and a way to build trust is is
by associating our website with other
websites of high equal or higher quality
so when we talk about off-site
engagement we want to do some guest
posts on relevant websites so if you
have that ice cream blog go to another
blog like the dessert blog and do a
guest post so not only that will that
improve your brand awareness but it'll
generate a backlink and maybe drive some
referral traffic you can participate in
forms and blog discussions like core.com
or Reddit get your content out there
start a discussion about a specific
topic to engage users build brand
awareness and generate that backlink you
can always you know put your your site
on a directory like Yelp for example or
Yahoo directory you could prefer
testimonial link building meaning if you
serve products or offer up a service
well somebody could provide a testimony
on their website or you can just earn
back links from relevant authoritative a
web pages like we mentioned quora or
Wikipedia or there's plenty out there so
the idea is to associate yourself with
high quality websites but do it
naturally you don't want to force
anything so if you're selling a specific
service or you're selling a specific
product look for like mining services or
products that complement what you do and
that'll create the natural environment
natural ecosystem that will eventually
give you the benefits that you need to
rank higher in the search results pages
so we don't want to purchase any links
we don't want to cloak content we don't
want to just inject links on sites that
aren't relevant we don't want to just
have site-wide links all over the place
pointing to the same page and we
certainly don't want to be on low
quality websites or directories it's all
about quality not quantity with off-site
engagement so having an offside
engagement complements what you do on
your website for on-site together both
of those efforts will get you higher
search engine results here we reach to
the end of this video before we wrap up
listening to the success story by our
Learners in their own words change is
inevitable but growth is optional
for me both came hand in hand
I successfully changed my career from
software development to digital
marketing and simply learned present at
the perfect route hi I'm rimajraf from
Dubai and I have completed the pgp in
digital marketing from Simply learn with
Purdue University when I shifted to
Dubai from Sri Lanka in 2015 I joined a
group of company as a software engineer
but my interest in content creation
attracted me towards the marketing
industry intrigued by the marketing
functions I decided to take up a
challenge that would change my life
forever I aim for a career change as
risky as it was the rewards were truly
overwhelming even though the journey
wasn't easy the pgp in digital marketing
with Purdue University acted as not only
a catalyst but a game changer for my
career change with no profiling
certification in marketing domain it was
difficult for me to transition and
change my career towards completely
so I decided to upskill with the
professional certification program
I just simply learn because of its
tremendously High waiting to be rated as
one of the best Education portal online
worldwide is surely promising not only
were the ratings I but also the courses
were economically charged the modules
were very informative and amazing I
still refer to those while in the final
stage of my course I told my Superior
about the certification program I was
doing and they offered me a digital
marketing role in the marketing
department as a digital marketing
executive is that's how smooth it was
after working for a few years in the
same company as a digital marketing
executive I switched to a new role as a
digital marketing manager with this my
skill upgraded my salary increase and my
self-confident Boost alongside numerous
other positive outcomes I had a chance
to take a challenge and change my career
domain all together
and I took it So currently I am pursuing
masters of Masters program from Simply
learn where I would complete a Masters
program including artificial
intelligence cloud computing and devops
and many more growing requires moving
out of our comfort zones
keep learning if you like this video
share it with your family and friends
and do not forget to subscribe to Simply
learn thanks for watching this video
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here